Are you should fear,
speed rapping and five,
four,
three,
two,
one go.
One of them said we got to sit in with
them or whether they've got money.
What I kind of like that we were talking
about how impressive Mac lethal is,
but then argos.
Yeah,
but you got to read the words otherwise
you have no idea.
Yeah.
That would be making anything up pain.
So in that sense I've gone too far.
He's like triple f tits.
You can't sing along with that,
the triple afterwards we're like,
I like my boobs.
Like I'll do like this much pressure.
Alright.
Who crushed beer cans with their fake
boobs and she knows,
yeah,
she knows the lie up your cancer.
Just smash them with the weight of their
ticket.
It's like the most unsexy thing ever.
It's like this hypersexuality gets
morphed into this weird distortion
that's sexual version of when your dog
catcher smoking is like,
that's what the whole pack of cigarettes
so much watch his gal.
She's got to Ted and she's smashing your
kids.
Do you imagine?
Course there are foster's fucking Bogan.
Australia is trail it shit.
That's hilarious.
Just straight from Tazzie look at those
fucking,
hey,
we get Steve Harvey,
Steve Harvey show.
They just went with fosters steric cause
she's got to be Australia.
That's why they want to foster is that
kind of behavior.
Maybe they just wanted a big cam because
smash big cans fosters,
there's a giant cans.
Maybe Budweiser didn't want any part of
it so they couldn't get a bud tall boy.
By the way.
You know nobody Australia drinks
fosters,
no,
they don't write.
You don't even have available and most
bars really?
Yeah.
It's not even like bud light where
nobody really drinks it but like sneaky
or just marketing.
Everything is marketing.
What is a beer like?
Our beer is pabst blue ribbon is kind of
fun because it's so white trash.
Pull out a can of paps.
Like I'll drink a can of paps at the
store sometimes.
I'm like,
do you mean like at the supermarket?
No College.
I was like,
what?
Like why are flops on harbage white with
flip flops on boxer shorts.
Fuck it.
Wife beater triggered up gigantic pabst
blue ribbon.
Normal Australian life photo.
That's a quarter of the men.
Would do that kind of shit like while
I'm shopping for other snacks.
I love it over there.
They're great people there.
If you were going to ask their beer like
that is vb.
VB,
yeah.
That's said there was another country
that I would live in besides America or
besides the United States.
It would be Canada and if there's
another country I'd live in besides
Canada,
it would be Australia for sure,
and Canada because it's right there.
It's too cold.
Not Vancouver.
Vancouver's too cold as well.
He could handle it.
Fine.
I can handle it.
You're a traveling man.
I skipped the fucking winter,
so I go traveling.
Oh,
you're out.
You're saying your travel.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're right.
If you just got there in the rainy
season,
which is like nine months,
three months are amazing.
I was doing the math on New York does to
the other day of like second.
How many actual months of Nice it is and
it's really a six and six.
Yeah.
Not even nine and three.
No,
it's not six and six.
Yeah.
Fuck.
Yeah,
it's,
there's,
there's some rugged days in those nice
months to,
you know,
all those,
like those six if you go like,
it's really probably nine,
but there's three months.
They're super sketchy.
Super Sketchy.
It snow in April.
We've got April this year.
Yeah.
That's annoying.
I was in Australia and I were there were
like,
it's snowing in New York and like that's
like a prince song by the way.
Stolen April.
Sometimes it snows in April.
Is that about cocaine?
Kind of is more sensitive ones?
No.
Oh,
it's about sadness.
I used to listen to it when I was
delivering newspapers.
I think it was great.
Mark Norman had a theory that was proven
wrong.
I guess that a prince,
when he died,
he died of the last of the eighties
aids.
He said he's been fighting it hard cause
of the money,
but he got it back actually fucked up.
He died from fentanyl man.
They all died from that fentanyl shit.
That stuff kills everybody.
They're testing drugs now at music
festivals.
They should that and they did it in
Australia when I was there.
They do it in UK in some places where
you just come and they chip off the
smallest amount and they text you get
your stuff is safe or not and then it's
way safer to do it.
Then just fucking passing around fat.
They need deregulation.
They just do.
They just need deregulation.
You're not saving anybody by making
drugs illegal.
You're just making it difficult to get
good drugs.
That's all you're doing.
You're not stopping people from doing
drugs and in fact when they legalize
things,
often teen use goes down because it's,
it doesn't become so attractive anymore,
but people are stupid.
All right,
we are wired fucked up and you can tell
us we can't do something.
That's the thing we want to do.
That's just how it is.
I will say,
to be fair,
I will say legalization of drugs would
make more people do it.
I would have to think it would.
Psychologically they say no when they've
done studies.
Nobody though.
There's some people that wouldn't
normally do and be like,
well,
there's a store right there.
All right.
Okay.
Sorry.
I don't know about that man.
I think it normalizes after awhile.
I think it starts off like that in the
beginning,
but I think what that is is the residual
effect of making it pro prohibited,
the residual effect.
But then once it becomes legal,
like alcohol,
if you're 21 you don't walk by cvs and
go,
I could just go buy it.
Why don't I just go get some whiskey?
Do you know?
I mean,
but people way more people drink than
two drugs.
Right,
but they don't do it because it's like a
new thing.
It's so easy to get it.
It's just there.
I'm sad.
You got to think.
Some people that would never would have
done it.
I have conservative friends from high
school that never would do it,
but if it was on the same levels,
alcohol in 20 years,
they'll be like,
oh,
okay.
I was my,
all my friends are doing it.
I don't know if it's worse.
I really just not worst.
I won't say it's worse.
I'm just saying there's some people who
would,
but I think overall you end up getting a
lot less people like total numbers to do
it well.
I think things would normalize.
I really do.
I think we have a real,
there's a,
it's a responsibility that I think
society has to,
this fucked up prohibition that we've
know is ridiculous.
We have too much information now.
We know too much about people
to make things prohibited when you make
other things that are just as dangerous
legal.
Right,
so it's all fucking farce.
Yeah.
It doesn't make any sense.
When alcohol is legal and marijuana
isn't,
or alcohol's legal,
mushrooms aren't,
you're talking nonsense.
People drink themselves to death every
day to death every day,
not just liver effects.
Alcohol poisoning.
Thousands of people every year die from
alcohol poisoning.
Did.
You can't do mushrooms that much.
You can't die from it.
You can't,
but it will just stop working on it.
You won't do it.
Exactly.
Keep doubling the dosage.
By the end of the week,
you'll be doing like a pound of
mushrooms and that's fine.
Yeah,
exactly.
I'm going to do that.
Your shit's will be crazy.
Well,
Dennis Mckenna,
who I had on last week,
his brother terrance had that theory
about human evolution and it's a very
compelling theory and there's firms make
human ability.
They might have caused it,
but it might've been one of several
factors.
There was several factors.
One of them was climate change,
like the monkeys had to move down from
the trees because there was no food left
and the grasslands had taken over where
the rain forest had been cause just
because of climate change.
But that was the same period where all
these undulates lift.
So all of these cow like creatures,
shit all over the place.
The mushrooms growing out,
these monkeys that were experimental,
the human monkey started eating these
things and then started developing
language skills,
more sophisticated hunting,
better visual because the visual
perception,
especially in low doses,
it actually increases acuity been proven
in scientific double blind placebo
controlled studies.
Yeah.
It increases visual cues,
increases your ability to recognize when
things are shifting.
Like say if you have two lines and one
of them slightly shifts,
like maybe a half of 1% angle that
people that were on mushrooms could see
it.
You ever see a clock or be able to see
them in a hand move,
like get zoned in where you can like
slow sort of see it move in a couple of
times,
but only because when I was little,
whoa.
But yeah,
that's what that kind of,
yeah,
we can like my vision sucks now dude.
When I look at a clock,
I look at like vague numbers like that,
that clock right now.
Like I look at that,
that little one right there.
Yeah,
I look at,
those are vague numbers.
You can't see those.
I can see him.
I know that's 12 months to close.
That's Peter went out,
look at this.
Bam.
Now I could see all the dots.
I could see everything.
Get the surgery.
No,
it's not that.
It's,
it's close.
It's near sightedness.
It's what happens when you get older.
It's just macular degeneration.
This is too near for you.
No,
no.
Things that are near don't look as good.
That's,
that's like a good medium distance,
but farther things look exactly the
same.
It's a slow degeneration of your
eyesight due to age.
My friend was not remembering my friend
Steve Graham,
he's an ophthalmologist.
He's like,
there's not a goddamn thing you can do
about it.
Doctor Steve with the,
yeah,
yeah.
From the US ski team.
He told me some great advice I will
share with everyone we were talking
about on my podcast.
We were talking with him about um,
the hours they put in and I was like,
if you're putting a 10 hours,
you can't be as good at four 30 as you
are because,
oh,
there's your,
should never make a doctor appointment
in the afternoon.
Ooh,
they're tired.
They're not giving you their work.
Wow.
Yeah.
He's like always make a morning
appointment when they actually had just
had their coffee.
Like,
all right,
let's start dude.
I had this guy,
Dr.
Matthew Walker on a couple of weeks ago.
It was a sleep specialist and was
talking about how important sleep is.
And one thing in common with a lot of
people that suffer from Alzheimer's is
they were getting like three,
four hours sleep at night.
They were those get up and go type
people.
Their brains wind up short.
Now he's saying that really sleep is
unbelievably important.
It's one of those podcasts,
you listen to it and it literally will
change your behavior patterns.
I don't know if we're changing,
my behavior does slip so fucking much.
I just stay in bed for like five hours
after I wake up and what's,
what's the point you live in the life?
Ours fear and a lot of ways if it's cold
out,
I've told everybody,
man at a,
all my friends that you know,
quote unquote made it,
it became successful.
You went the full whole hog.
You like the one who never got caught in
any of the trappings.
You got snipped.
You've said,
fuck it,
I want to live in New York.
It,
fuck it.
I want to disappear in Asia for three
months.
They tell you to do something with your
TV show and you're like,
fuck you.
It's over.
And I mean,
you're really doing what everybody wants
to do.
I have one fuck you moment ever.
Like that really is when uh,
I had a book deal and I gave them the
money back.
I didn't know like they were trying to
fuck with it too much.
I was like,
this is annoying.
Take your money back.
Felt great to be the only real control
once you feel,
I feel more free that anyone ever,
I look around on this matrix level of
like,
why don't you guys have more freedom for
yourselves?
Yeah,
you've got the most freedom out of all
my friends were talking about with
Burton,
they see it.
They were like,
we were talking about what B and b of
each other's lives,
you know,
their family life,
where's my whatever life.
And they were like,
Bart was like,
what do you think I envy about?
I'm like,
Huh?
I was like,
it's my freedom.
And he was like,
I have just much freedom was due.
And I was like,
I just,
I laugh.
I was like,
what are you talking about?
Fuck,
are you talking about it?
But it doesn't make any sense.
He was like,
what do you mean brandy's?
He had to explain it to them.
He goes already could just from here.
Just go away.
Not Call anybody.
Yeah,
just go from here.
Whatever.
He's got it.
Just go away.
Yeah.
You can't do that.
If you didn't tell me you were going and
you vanish for a few months,
I would call the police.
You would?
Yeah,
cause I would worry about you.
But once you tell me like I'm going to
go to Asia,
my car,
I,
dude,
I guess I'll talk to you when you get
back.
People got so worried.
They're like,
what's happens if you get arrested?
I'm like,
I'm going to do the time,
Bro.
I don't know.
I'll figure out a way to get to the
embassy maybe,
but,
but if you just vanished,
you kind of have a little bit of
responsibility for people that care
about you.
You don't want to hurt their feelings
and just let the word out.
Yeah.
I think don't tell them,
hey,
I'm going.
Then they have to deal with,
they might miss you,
but they just have to deal with it.
They don't have to like freak out.
Like what happened to our,
yeah.
I told my parents wasn't a disappear on
though.
That's good.
Yeah.
You got to tell your parents,
but certain people fuck it.
Let them figure it out by manager got so
mad.
She was like,
you can't not tell me where you're going
and not be able to reach you.
I'm like,
Oh,
I definitely can.
I'm doing that because that's not,
I was like,
if it makes you feel better,
I'm not.
My mom had a rich
man.
That does make me feel better.
There's something to what you did
though.
I think it's you.
I felt you felt like a little different
to me when he came back.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like you had just,
you know,
you'd had so many experiences.
I think everything fades away.
Responsibility was,
I'm reading this book,
the talent code,
you ever heard of it?
It's a really interesting book where
they analyze performers and different,
different venues,
like different things that they do.
Different sports,
different art.
Yeah.
And Jackson's who?
Greg Jackson,
amazing book I think for anybody and it
makes you really realize first of all
how many sets you should be doing.
He should be doing a ton of long sets.
As many law.
The most time on stage you have the
better.
It's very critical like the longer long
sets because an hour like you're going
to perform.
If you're headlining the most you can do
those the better because you really
there.
That's a different thing when you do a
weekend,
don't you feel like if you do Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday at a comedy club,
Saturday night late show you are fucking
colliding
fire and if I do like the third straight
week of five show weekends by then it's
like,
oh you guys are getting it right.
Wonderful show right now.
Do you just get smooth?
Yeah.
I the one of the smoothest I ever got
was I did that a maxim tour with Charlie
Murphy and half Ron and dude,
we did 22 dates in a month or we were
just,
oh we just go on stage.
You're like in this zen state,
you're just,
you're doing so much stand up.
That's how I come back from Edinburgh.
Yeah.
You just 25 straight days of an hour and
I,
and then you're like,
you're just,
you have to tweak it a little when you
get home.
But like it's just like you're there,
you're just doing it over and over again
all the way.
I think in the beginning of standup when
you're starting,
I think lots of sets are good cause then
you learn how to win over a crowd a
bunch of times.
So three new crowds is better than one
45 minutes to completely agree.
But then yeah,
once you're doing it longer,
it's like
look at it like form your hour.
Well this is what I was getting to with
that talent code book.
Oh yeah.
It is on development of skills.
Just talking about how many amazing
Brazilian soccer players came out of
this one area and they were trying to
figure it out and they realize,
oh it was,
they have this other game that they play
with a smaller,
heavier ball and it's harder.
And so they do that game and it's like
in clothes co they'll do it in like a
room,
like a small room.
Like this room.
They'll play the soccer game and they
get amazing footwork and movement
because that,
because they're in such close quarters,
they,
they're very fast.
And so they take those skills and apply
them to soccer,
football,
whatever they call it.
And it's fucking amazing how much they
excel.
This is what I'm talking to some of
those roasts battle guys.
Mm.
There's always rose pedal cars and you
know,
they're not like,
as,
as developed.
It's on stage as they are for those rose
petals.
Yeah.
But some of them like Joe Dosh,
people like that,
the kill [inaudible] when those roles
paddles.
So then it's like,
what are you doing?
So it's talking to Eli Sayers,
who's like unified champ and a,
we figured out like,
you just take those,
those rows style jokes and applied them
to the guy next to you and traffic or
whatever.
Like you've really just,
just roasting any topic,
you know,
that comes up.
But you just got to leave.
That should eventually yet no.
Dot.
I think there's good training.
Cross training.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
I think there's things like that with
everything.
And I think with you,
what I was recognized,
I was like,
oh,
he's just sorta like data crunched all
these cultures over four months.
Like you came back with like you,
you had like last patience for stupidity
and,
and more like a,
a more expanded,
uh,
to how to,
it's hard to gauge someone's
understanding of the world,
but the way you talked about things,
I was like had a more expanded view of
things you like,
wow.
You know,
just,
just America,
you know,
like your perspective is like you got
everybody who thinks that this is the
word you crazy.
This is just America.
We spend so much time in this bubble,
but when you are out there for like four
months,
you came back.
It was almost like you were like,
oh,
okay.
And I think as a human is this,
and I think this is one of the things
that happens bad to comedians when they
become successful,
which is one of the reasons why they
drop off.
They get really famous,
really powerful because they don't take
any new experiences in because they
don't take any risks because too many
people like them when they go on stage.
I know that played in your own crowd.
His crowd is terrible,
but also play to your own crowd is your
fault.
Here's why you should know if your stuff
is good and you should be working on it,
you should be listening to your
recordings.
You should listen to them and go,
is this something that I would want to
pay to see?
Right,
and if it's not,
let me fix it because like I'm in this
stage right now,
the right and new act stage where Max
terrible right now.
I still have the old material that I'll
have to abandon when a October comes
around the special airs,
but until then I'm just developing shit
and the new stuff.
It's like I've got six new minutes that
are worth hearing and they'll a lot of
stuff fucking super clunky.
But if you don't do it,
if you don't scare yourself and if you
don't experience new things,
you don't have you,
you have to know whether your stuff's
any good.
Okay.
And if you,
if you're not looking at it,
not paying attention,
it happens to a lot of famous comedians.
Their specials as they get older,
get softer,
softer,
and,
and there's just,
kinison was always my favorite example
because he's one of my all time.
If not,
he's like prior and Kennison to me are
like,
that's my mount rushmore,
you know,
in Lenny Bruce,
just for creating the whole thing.
But I have an idea I want to talk to you
about like,
I forgot,
but when you watch early kinison he was
a fucking monster.
The best.
Who's the best?
And it was such a short time,
but with him it wasn't like a sustained
success to drop.
It was like,
oh,
he went crazy.
He went crazy.
He's hanging out with Bon Jovi and doing
blow and bang and strippers.
And being that guy,
he's being that rockstar comedian guy
and he didn't write anymore.
You could tell he was getting by on
songs and dances,
you know?
He was just like show business of
himself.
Remember the todd?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So he went crazy.
Right.
You know the todd got me into the store.
Really?
Yeah.
He's the reason I got into the store.
He told me how to do it too.
And you told me you're going to do that
for your friends.
Sit next to Mitzi and when your friends
on stage,
you laugh hard and Mitzi,
you go along with you.
Oh did he did that.
He sat right next to Mitzi.
Mitzi goes,
Mitzi,
this kids fucking hilarious.
She goes,
oh,
okay,
I'll watch.
I'm just sort of believed that and I got
lucky.
I had a great set and then,
but the todd was probably the loudest
voice in the room.
He was in the back laughing his ass off.
Wow.
I do that for anybody that I remember.
You did it from required for whatever
else.
Anybody if you're,
if you're,
if you're doing a viewer performing for
Mitzi,
I had to sit next to Mitzi.
I,
we used to sit next to her where my
friends would showcase just so these
fucking cock blocks wouldn't come in and
try to talk to you.
It's true too.
It's like,
what are you doing in the middle of
sets?
Somebody performing for their future.
That's a shift change to the queen.
52 minutes.
They're just leave her alone.
So you just have to block,
you get three minutes in front of the
Queen of comedy.
Yeah.
And these fucking cock blockers.
So,
so,
oh the todd,
okay,
here's what I'm going to say about that
in terms of just like curious and being
a character himself.
So he went crazy,
but that was before he went crazy.
There was a thing he used to do where he
would go to the bartenders and take like
a glasses off and then just like as
staring them down and just chuck it in
the garbage just to like keep up with
them,
you know?
And then when he went crazy,
I mean,
literally crazy.
Yeah.
He's sorta half remember doing that but
different Bartz who just take them and
kind of like throw them in the garbage
but not cleaner even know why he was
doing it.
He was just like a pallette out version
was up.
That's how Kennison was.
He was like yelling,
right?
No Man have rage.
Not just yelling.
Yeah,
it was.
It didn't make any sense anymore.
There was no point.
It was just,
he was just trying to perform and ride
the wave,
but in the beginning he was angry.
So good.
He was so angry.
They asked him,
how come you don't make fun of men as
much to make fun of women?
He goes,
because a man has never born and make me
drive my car into a tree.
He used to play that song.
I want my fucking records back by rap.
God help you.
It's fine.
Under a gas truck.
Yeah.
Fuck it was good.
Well,
you believed it.
He was just short,
fat,
ugly guy who was just screaming at the
world for all of his pain.
You knew he was in pain and then when he
wasn't in pain anymore,
it wasn't fun.
Then he wasn't in pain anymore.
That he was like,
he was just this superstar and then it
just didn't work as a superstar.
It's weird.
Yeah.
So you're saying a lot of these guys
don't enter into new experiences.
You have to have new challenges,
new experiences.
You have to be excited,
be excited about some new thoughts.
And I think that much like these
Brazilian soccer players from what does
named Daniel coyle is who we are.
What's the author's name?
Daniel coyle.
Um,
when he talked about these Brazilian
soccer players playing this tight room,
the skills they developed in this really
tight environment help them in the game.
I think life is like what the training
ground for standup is.
And if your life is the same boring shit
calling your agent,
you know,
what do we got for me?
You've got a script for me drawing from,
you don't have any,
where's your real world?
You really can't talk about that
Hollywood shit.
It's boring and people don't relate to
it.
Some people could.
Kathy Griffin,
that's all she talks about.
It's like,
yeah,
I mean,
but it's okay for her and that's her
thing.
She likes to do it.
Yeah.
People who like her,
like it,
it's no big deal,
but not for me.
It's not for me and not for you.
I want to relate to someone coming to
see my show.
But you want to relate to yourself to
write,
write half things to be like,
oh,
let me share this with you.
Yes.
You want to do stand up the you would
pay for.
Right,
right,
right.
Which is hard to be conscious of the
audience,
all of that man.
Because you know there's,
you have to figure out why you're doing
what you're doing.
To like,
am I doing what I'm doing just to get a
laugh or am I doing what I'm doing
because I would actually like it.
Yeah.
Just cause I know it's working doesn't
mean it's good.
Yeah.
And with that,
with traveling over it,
whatever,
it's like half,
it was like,
let me get some new experiences to draw
from.
The other half is just let me just
challenge myself in moments.
Yes,
I can practice overcoming things,
you know?
Yeah.
It's a crazy businessmen,
crazy business.
And it,
unless you're on top of your own
thoughts,
you got to be up on yourself.
That's like,
it's like college stuff from high school
where they're like,
look,
they don't care in college,
they're going to let you fail.
They're not going to say,
where's that report?
Yeah.
You know,
this is even more intense.
This is working for some really high
pressure corporation.
Don't even understanding at least in
college you were like,
oh I gotta go do this homework.
Be like,
okay,
I get that.
If you're like,
I can't,
I've got to go over my set.
Like what do it later?
What do you mean?
What?
Why?
And nobody gets went up yesterday.
You don't have to go up again.
Well not only that,
who would you talk to to try to explain
it?
There is maybe a thousand of us on earth
artists know.
Yeah,
yeah.
They do a real,
if you can start something like that.
My thing is what I,
yeah,
but if you talk about like how many
headliners are there on earth?
Is there a thousand?
We're not talking cruise ships.
No,
no,
no.
I'm talking about someone who can get a
special right.
Someone who comedy central would watch
or Netflix would walk through Amazon
category of getting especially uh,
yeah,
but probably not a thousand.
So that's not a lot of people.
Yeah.
It's a shit small amount of people for
an awesome job.
So you've got to figure out,
well why,
why is this a small amount of people?
Because it's a bloody fucking
catastrophe leading up to success.
There's no chance of money early on,
not even a chance and go and go,
I'm going to make it.
It was like,
okay,
if you on a fast track is going to be
seven years,
if you're on the fat side,
if you're on the fast track,
like it ain't around the corner dude.
And you're subject to bombing and like
jump off a bridge bombing at any one of
those years.
Oh yeah.
Jump off a bridge about the cult.
I was trying to explain to them what the
cold sweats where and how.
It's like,
hey,
almost like out of it,
you feel the sweat but it's,
you're shivering at the same time.
Y'All was the worst for me laying in bed
at night after the show.
Oh you're going over it.
Everything went wrong.
Wrenching.
Oh fuck.
Beyond embarrassing him.
It's beyond embarrassment.
Just ruthless destruction of your self
esteem.
Just Ah,
fuck.
You know,
there's a lot of people that just won't
go back after that.
Why would you,
why would you that's uh,
what,
uh,
theory not what's before theory,
hypothesis.
Cause I haven't proven it all.
Why there's fewer women in stand up.
Cause my friend who's a researcher's
like women's Development,
Rachel Simmons swings books on it.
Uh,
she said that women just,
I don't know if it's,
I forget it,
but sociologically or physically,
probably sociologically or less able to
accept rejection early on.
It's just,
that doesn't go with it who they are.
Um,
and so they just like don't do those
things.
And so you have to push them.
If you have daughters you have to push
them to like try and fail and try and
fail because failure makes you succeed.
But early on in stand up it's only
failure.
Yeah,
so if your gender's less into that,
let's taking that like outside rejection
or something and you're like,
oh I don't want to do this.
We didn't want to do it.
Sexist is fuck and after denounce you
now publicly.
That's fair.
I have to go on twitter and tell
everybody your supporting gender
stereotypes say it definitely met,
have forced women to not be able to
accept rejection.
Put them in this category where they
can't accept projection.
Perfect.
Which proves that when men and women are
equal,
so when they,
now when they've been socialized by a
patriarchy to not accept that they would
then they go into an environment where
it's only failure and they go,
I don't want to do this.
I think if I had to guess,
I think standup is at least 20 to 25%
harder for women.
This is why I think there's subjects
that,
especially when you're starting out,
men don't want to hear from you in the
audience.
Men Don't want to hear about politics.
You have a bigger hurdle when it comes
to points of view,
politics or advice.
Anything where a woman is like saying
like a guy who can get on stage and say,
listen guys,
you want to fucking get your life in
order.
You got to stop Blah Blah button.
Then the jokes set up and then go on.
But a woman would have a hard time
giving advice given by,
okay,
I can see that did buy meatheads right.
If let's say this might be true because
I,
when I say young comics,
the stock make a gender actors,
young comics talking about politics,
what's got to change?
A part of me goes like 26 year old
apartment goes shut the fuck up so you
don't know what the fuck you're talking
about.
So anyone 26 would have to deal with and
I think women have that shit too.
Yeah.
They have like,
I want to hear this from you.
And then they have that deep into their
thirties and forties because men don't
want to hear it from chicks about
politics.
Oh,
let me go.
She fucking wish Hillary won.
Jesus starts a shocker.
You know,
there's like this gender,
uh,
like biases that a lot of men have about
a woman getting onstage talking,
controlling all the attention.
They don't like it.
And I'll,
a lot of men have the,
I'm not saying it's right or wrong,
it's just I,
but I'm just being honest about
instincts.
There's an instinct to not like it.
Yeah.
There's another reason too,
it's that,
uh,
Taylor's theory,
which I like,
is it women on stage early on?
Oh,
this is why it's harder for men.
It's just the first six months or so
women just the first six months,
women are used to people looking at
them.
And for men it's this weird new thing
where it's like,
why you looking at me as strange?
Showing the first like right away and
open mics like early on,
women are way more comfortable on stage
of the men.
Hmm.
For the most part and then that it evens
out,
but those first few months it's this
thing of like,
um,
this is not a comfortable thing.
Women,
it's a negative that I've had to deal
with that their whole lives but like
people are staring at them all the time.
I think we struggle with this idea of
like,
like saying that I think it's harder for
women.
I think it's harder for men because it's
a generalization to,
it's like overall some hard,
it's harder for that.
Some men it's where he's report
whatever.
That's when the black and white it,
it's when you fucking ruined all the
arguments.
I know it's just like 10% harder,
15% owner.
I think one of the reasons it is harder
careerwise for,
I mean almost all women is because uh,
success too early can hurt you in the
long run.
If you start thinking I'm good instead
of thinking you're terrible,
you don't work as hard.
That's just human nature thing.
More for women than for men because
we're in such a category of needing
women performers that we go earlier and
earlier in development in order to plug
them up.
Huh.
Because I,
if I need to put a woman on stage on TV,
you know,
and there's,
this developed women Silverman.
It's like I ain't doing that.
I don't want to Saguaros.
Yeah,
sure.
Okay.
Uh,
so you have to get some women,
you have to have chemisch show somebody
at home,
your own the version of yourself.
Right.
And if there's women viewers got to put
a woman on,
Huh.
You know,
if you have a lot of comics,
but if I'm getting this as a single
individual performer,
if I'm getting something five years in
and I start going,
yeah,
I'm pretty fucking good.
I don't have to work this hard.
You know,
when I start getting more and more
things,
I work less and less hard.
It's another reason why the fucking
celebrity comics aren't as good as non
celebrity comics.
Um,
but if you start getting stuff,
you start like,
I don't need to work that hard to get
it.
If you have to study for an hour to get
an a,
you know what I mean?
Then why would you study for seven
hours?
Right.
An hour gets you there.
So if you start getting success career
wise,
like monetarily,
you stop working as hard on the artistic
part of it.
You can,
you can stop.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I think you're 100% right.
Yeah.
So this is the drop off.
It sorta does them a disservice as he
has an individual that gets stuff,
but at the same time you want to,
so I mean,
as a former booker,
as a booker,
all you gotta do is look harder to get
qualified women go to Indianapolis Five
Ms Pat,
I mean they're out there,
but to prop somebody up who doesn't
quite deserve it only hurts them in the
long run.
Yeah.
There's the problem also is that you
want to find a certain number,
like comedy should be almost totally
egalitarian.
Yeah.
It should be just performance based.
I mean,
I think if a club has a developmental
project,
like Wendy does the works in Denver,
than it might not be a bad idea to have
all girl classes.
I bet that would give you a bump for
anybody who feels uncomfortable and
wants to learn how to do standup with
all one of those is harder for for
checks early on is because there's
crepes and open mikes.
Oh yeah.
They're not weeded out like there aren't
clubs.
The clubs there was like,
get out of here.
We don't want you here.
I'd open my any fucking freak that's
there.
And Man,
that is not a fun experience to deal
with.
That's why I think that drives around
with the most right away.
Early on.
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
Shitty.
Nobody's good.
And then also I got this fucking smelly
guy fucking leering over me.
Fuck this.
A hundred percent a hundred percent I
mean it's nightclub,
creepiness plus crazy people.
So you have regular night nightclub,
creepiness,
and then you have open mikes.
Just always a certain percentage of
people that are insane.
It's literally insane.
Insane.
Yeah.
Homeless people.
And they get to go up front of you.
You're like,
what?
What?
I've tried same Mike.
He's the same as you.
Oh,
I forgot about that.
Yeah.
Who knows what kind of Shit you getting
off that mic on an open mic night and
the store,
especially back in the day,
they didn't fix nothing with that Mike,
I'll clean.
That thing was growing all kinds of shit
on at least it didn't have a foam top
like this does to hold.
I had to change his phone one cause it
smelled like my breath.
I was like getting up in the air.
I was like,
smell a person on this.
We get a mic that smelled so bad at
cobb's this weekend that I've mentioned
it to simone and it was like both like
it was taking us out of it like 30
minutes in and usually get used to it.
I'm like,
Oh fuck,
that's it.
Good.
He said he was made that it was holding
the mic different regular metal at
holding it different so we can get it
away from his nose.
Who was there before you?
I don't know.
I think it was all of us just like,
oh yeah,
these foam things are disgusting.
You know,
some people have those circles.
I have those circles for a while.
They'll spit shields but it seems so
pretentious.
They seem pretentious.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Those seem where it hop,
pop filter a pop filters that they seem
super pretentious.
They seem like what are you doing?
Stupid but that fucking Hula Hoop in
front of your face.
So I had a couple ideas on acid.
This music festival,
what I want to run by you and that one,
it was fun time by the way.
What music festival?
A firefly in Delaware.
Nice bus from New York and then you just
go there camp and have a fucking good
time.
And I'm fucking just like laying down on
my back trying to keep my eyes open so I
can,
my friends went off to the bathroom,
like could be here.
I'm like,
I'll be right here.
I'm not going anywhere right now.
And so keep my houses that people don't
look at you like what's wrong with you?
You know,
it's just see a few stars and you'd be
out of it.
Eyes Open,
but just out of it.
And then every once I fucking love music
festivals,
man,
you come out of it and then some fucking
guy dressed like a wood nymph.
You're like,
what the fuck?
Anyways,
Dad,
I just heard somebody go,
I never want to get that fucked up.
Fire me.
I was like,
fuck.
So as idea,
you know,
I do those um,
album breakdowns,
my podcast,
first album breakdowns.
Uh,
I want to do one with you on Sam
Kennison his album.
Ooh.
Just us.
Listen to it.
Like talk about it and analyze it and
stuff.
Yeah,
let's do it.
Let's do louder than hell.
Do you know louder than hell?
You can't get on CD.
You can.
Cause it was so homophobic that the
people at Warner brothers,
they put it out on a cassette,
but then they never released it on cd
when cds came along and I'm like,
fuck that fat slob.
Wow.
Yeah,
dude,
he's gonna Forget.
Let me tell you how much she had to
overcome.
I was around during the pc days of the
eighties were in a pc war.
Right now.
Seems like it's just a battlefield.
It's just gone crazy.
Like there's more bombs going off pc
wise and ever.
People are so invested in the idea of
controlling behavior and telling people
what to do.
But back then it was happening too for a
while with the,
with the member,
the music,
Tipper Gore,
Al Gore's wife,
his wife was trying to make it a speech
but there's some things that go too far.
Yeah she was trying to ban rap music and
so things got things got real weird.
Same language over and over again.
MTV banned dice clay for life cause he
told some joke about girls and their
periods or something.
I would love to hear what that joke was
and see if we can actually like that's a
goddamn badge of courage for a guy like
dice just gave him a gold medal.
That's all it really does for him.
He doesn't give a fuck.
That guy legitimately doesn't give a
fuck cause like I was definitely going
to be good anyway.
He'll,
he walks around,
he makes videos walking around the
supermarket talking about his haircut.
I got this new hair cut.
What do you think?
Not make another video.
This fucking haircut.
That guy doesn't give a fuck.
Like literally it's just doing whatever
dice wants to do.
Wandering through the world,
hanging out with his kids.
So like for him like getting banned from
MTV was probably the greatest thing
ever.
This is it at it.
Wow.
That bravado though.
Look it up.
Come on man.
Oh my God.
Oh,
zero out of nuts,
bro.
What the fuck you what?
Jessica Zebra.
I'd like to welcome you today.
My name is dyce.
I'm here to say I was born in Brooklyn.
Sheepshead bay come a long way to make
your smile.
I'm going to do with different going to
do with dice style.
What is the,
is this playing on youtube or is it not
true?
Was to rewind that.
Look how fucking nervous he is.
Rewind that 10 seconds.
Look,
it pulls the hand row.
Look at it.
Shake it.
I'm here to say I was born in Brooklyn.
Sheepshead bay come a long way to make
your smile.
I'm going to do with different going to
do with night style.
You see him shaking?
Yeah,
that's true.
It's all bravado and then he's like,
shit,
I'm doing this.
Okay,
my Spidey,
what?
Shane up Ho Bitch.
That
was the weirdest kind of comedy that he
could do it.
They knew what you were going to say and
they wanted to hear it start calming.
A complete,
original,
complete original.
If you just like people look at him
like,
Oh,
brutish and disgusting and dirty jokes
and misogynist.
All those things are true but,
but you got to realize that he
revolutionized like he did something but
he broke through some weird rock star
style.
Also,
if you just look at it completely
objectively,
forget about the artistic merits of what
he did.
He did something very different.
He figured out a way to do comedy that
people legitimately laughed at even
though they knew it was coming that
hadn't been done before,
that hadn't been dealt with like that.
Never,
never.
No one yells out the punchlines in front
of the whole crowd.
What's in the bow bitch.
He needed the money.
Oh,
everybody wanted to hear the things that
he had already said,
which never existed before.
He can fucking tour with that original
act right now and people would be super
satisfied,
let's say along with them.
Dice,
get to 10,000
seat arenas with that original act.
What's in the bow bench has not much to
go crazy.
Nothing comedy wise,
nothing.
It's the opposite of regular comedy.
It's the hair there,
but not much crushers.
Machine thing.
Yeah,
but he forces that on people.
I saw Gaffigan and at moontower once and
he did 45 minutes.
It's fine.
It was great and he does the old stuff.
Yeah.
Then he was like,
yeah,
he introduced it like that.
He goes,
yeah,
I'll probably just go back to my hotel
Roman.
When I say,
when I say burt forces on people,
let me explain what I'm saying.
Like he like that's his signature thing.
I don't mean it like in a negative way,
but I mean like he's,
he's scared to not do that.
He wants to do that.
He wants them to know him as that
machine.
He wants to do that bit everywhere and
he feels like they get upset if he
doesn't do it.
So in his head,
like he's,
he's forcing it on them,
therefore seeing on him and it's like
he's developed this,
everybody knows that if you're a fan of
Bert Kreischer,
you know the bit,
it's a fucking amazing.
He says you want to see this?
But he's like,
do you want to see them?
And then he's so worried about them
getting upset that they don't hear it,
but he's not at all concerned with how
they feel about him pledging $10,000
a children's hospital and not doing it
at all.
Just our food in the pantry.
I don't want to,
I don't want to get one.
I can't believe you brought that up.
One of the best trolls of all time,
him on children's hospital at gray.
Let's,
um,
let's talk about your job.
Don't you think that that's a different
thing when you,
when you have a bit like a signature bit
that you do every time you go on stage
and people expect to hear it,
that's a different thing.
Different thing.
Yes.
Then than regular standard comedy is
like when I'm watching your set,
like say if you have a new bit and I
haven't seen it before,
I'm,
I get excited because I don't know where
you're going and you're taking me down a
road and then you saw can do that
though.
Bobby Lee.
It's like it's just goofy.
You just want to see him do it.
Yeah.
It certain comics that are just like,
I don't know,
I just like seeing this over and over
in Boston,
Boston,
like all the headliners would do the
same act forever.
I know.
That's why I fuck all them.
Well that's why it fell apart.
Yeah,
right,
right.
Only only lasted for a little while like
that.
That's why it's adventure.
It's like,
yeah,
you haven't written a case up.
They had the opposite of an Internet age
approach.
Their age approach was you put together
a 45 minutes sat and that's it.
And some of them literally only had 45
minutes.
They'd been doing comedy for decades
because even with dice,
let's say you compare that to music
where everyone's singing along with it.
Musicians have new albums and then you
expand that catalog of stuff you can
sing along with,
hopefully up to a point up to a point.
And then we're rolling stones,
put some stuff out today.
Number.
He's like,
whatever,
brown sugar,
come on you fuck.
Let me see you dance.
I heard you could still dance,
dude.
I went to see a look to see,
um,
uh,
rancid,
it a,
a coney island.
Mm.
And um,
and um,
he said something,
he goes,
uh,
hey,
we can do some off the new album and
stuff.
It goes boom.
You know,
it's kind of like a of 2000 or something
like I heard you can pull if you want.
I'm still doing it.
Fucking went into it.
That's hilarious.
Ooh,
there's something off the new one.
Boom.
It's like people are so gross.
They didn't even like internalize that
feeling.
They want you to react to it,
but there's such a different thing
between feeling something and then
forcing everyone around you to hear it
and then forcing the artists to react to
it.
There's such the levels of Douche
baggish nest.
It takes the critical level.
Fucking asshole.
He heard it.
How to say something cause it's such
what he responded.
So that guy wins in that world of
Internet trolls.
If you could say something to the crowd
in a perfect moment of silence,
you know,
we're just naturally comes up.
That's audience member fucking
superbowl.
Yeah.
You,
you cracked one over the thing.
Patrick Ewing was like,
I think playing the supersonics.
This was like way after his prime.
He's just travel and how to get a couple
extra bucks and try to maybe win a
title.
Um,
and he went down the lane,
put up like a finger roll,
like halfway down the lane and just kind
of went up an air ball and went out of
bounds was a whistle only cause we went
out of bounds.
Whatever we thought was there a foul or
anything and then the rest could go out
of balance.
And we're just a silence my friends had
here.
That's it.
Somebody just go road tie.
Oh my God.
It's like sports fans.
The war was,
they're the worst.
They're the worst when it comes to that
shit.
It's like they feel like since day had a
regular job and they paid a lot of money
to come see you do that.
You better fucking do it.
Good.
There's posts you doesn't want to get
off the bench.
Your name about the your town,
that means the todd owns you.
It's not the fucking La Rogan's.
You know it's true.
Fuck it.
La Lakers and they're putting out a
shitty product.
Yeah.
How's your season been these last couple
of years?
Has it been bad?
It's been terrible.
You're very excited.
Oh,
I love it.
Almost like nothing else I've seen.
Oh Dude.
I love it.
I even all my sports fans like fandom.
I am at most a laker hater.
Fuck them at all.
They're fucking fans.
You guys have one of the worst franchise
in basketball.
People look at you when you tried to
recruit them and they go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
And they leave and Joyce,
showtime bitches.
It's been years since you've been in the
playoffs.
No draft pick this year.
Wow.
This is,
oh yeah,
it's great.
I can't understand that.
The next big noise.
When that rapist gets into the hall of
fame and all the fucking bloggers here,
pretend to forget about it again.
Fuck all you hypocrites.
Fuck you bitches.
All of you Lakers suck and you gotta
deal with it.
This is outrageous.
It's great viral team.
Better than yours.
Wow.
What team are you?
It doesn't even matter.
The point is the Lakers suck hotels fan.
We made it stuck around for the first
time in history.
Pelicans,
newer Lens Pelicans.
How did you get to be a fan of the,
because they started in North Carolina
when I was there.
Then they moved and then they change
their goddamn name.
It's all a mess,
but fucks my team.
Since day one,
a team called the Pelican,
not me.
The Go,
the wife of the guy who owns it.
He owns a good franchise as a fucking
billionaire.
Smart Guy who makes up the fucking
living for himself and he's like,
oh,
dumb fucking trophy wife.
You want to name the team?
Then all these men have to fucking
support.
Wow.
Is that really what happened?
That's what happened to your variant.
It's fucking ridiculous.
Very upset.
What would you have called it if you
were at [inaudible] house?
The bath mats.
It's a better fucking name than the
Pelicans.
I had to research all the time,
but like vicious Pelican behavior so I
could get behind a little bit.
They are vicious though.
Belly ducks whole.
They'll eat ducks hole.
They'll go down there and to be no
ducting to go fuck off.
I'm not sure I could watch that.
Oh,
it's great.
I'm sure we're going to watch Pelikan
eats a duck,
but no one thinks of that.
When you think of a Pelican,
no.
You think of like a cute thing that
brings babies.
Yeah.
Yeah,
let's do it.
That store.
Oh,
whoa,
whoa.
Back that up and show the golf.
It just shows it in there.
Wow.
Look at that.
Trying to get away.
Look at that thing.
Battling it out and be like,
you ain't going anywhere.
My biggest made a rubber and he's just
holding on and letting that thing pound
on them.
That's crazy.
Oh Shit.
There's a bunch of ducks.
Evil little fucking animal.
Oh,
it's a seagull eating pigeons.
Siegel.
Each pigeons.
Oh Jesus.
Wow.
That's God that is caused it and all
these people.
You just have to watch.
Oh,
these little kids and I'm fucking
bicycle boats.
This is nuts.
I did not know seagulls did that.
Seagulls,
Merck pigeons and eat them.
This is fucking know.
Oh my God.
Look,
it's feathers all falling off in this
pitch was like,
wait,
what?
What birds brows were both birds.
Oh,
he almost got away.
Look at this.
I found it.
Decapitated pigeon is
he's trying to get away.
Look at him.
Fuck you bitch.
In the street you founded decapitated
one replicated.
Um,
you know it's usually owls that do that
apparently attack they pipe.
Bite their fucking heads outside of
Ralph Hawks.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
hawks do it though.
There was,
oh.
Oh.
What happened there?
Did the bird get away?
It's completely switched to different.
Oh,
I got away and went after him.
Who sent this birds next.
But it seems like he got away.
Did Not believe that.
That that part was fine.
Watch.
Hold on.
No,
he's fucked up.
He's going to get fucked up.
Look.
See,
he's swimming away.
That things right after.
I mean,
I ain't going anywhere.
Thank you.
Right.
That's seagulls walking like Jesus on
top of the water over it.
I know those giant fee.
No chance.
That duck kind of like almost walk and
use their wings and they can run the
water.
Yeah,
the pigeons fucked.
I would love to have flight.
What would you give up?
What'd you give up?
Hearing or eyesight?
Hearing.
You can't do flight without sight.
You're fucked.
Well,
he could be a bat.
We get this one oof the whole duck.
That is fucking insane,
dude.
That's trying to drive them off the
other ducks mad like come on and give it
back and forth.
Dammit.
He's down.
He's in there.
Give me back my friend.
Look,
he's just swallows.
One more time.
Let me see that again.
That just grabs them.
I call it,
call it ball.
I'll,
I'll look at the size of that fucking
beak on that thing.
What a creepy animal.
Yeah.
Kicking inside of his body ball.
I'm full now.
Thank you.
I'm full Pelican.
Each pigeon.
St James Park in London.
Here we go there.
Oh,
that's dark.
I bet he does it every day,
but it looks like a monster.
He looks like a mom.
So this all looks like normal,
normal animals that looks like on
Australia type animal.
Have you ever seen a shoe bill?
No.
They're the creepiest bird over there.
They're a bird that lives in the Congo
in Africa.
It's a fucking prehistoric dinosaurs
bird.
And uh,
there's a video from the Congo.
Look at that thing.
There's some creepy head on pictures of
it.
Where you go,
what?
God.
That one,
that thing is a hatchet for a face,
man.
That by the way is pretty much the
Pelicans logo dude.
Well they should have made it the shoe
bills.
Yeah,
they should've fucking birdman.
There's videos of these things.
What's it like?
Oh,
it's okay.
Oh my God.
It's like,
it keeps shifting its head back and
forth,
but you look at its mouth.
It's mouth is like a giant pair of
scissors or something.
It's like,
it's creepy fucking animal do.
They left the Congo Congo there five
feet tall to a giant has bird.
So that's a Bobby Lee size bird.
Wow.
That's a smaller one there.
There's a crazy video of one in the
concepts being a snake head.
They don't weigh that much.
Birds are pretty light.
Even like a bigger bird,
like a Turkey that catch that fucking
fish air motherfucker.
How's he gonna throw it?
Throw.
It was letting them know that it's in
the bucket.
I just going to go for it.
Watch how they were Walkman.
They just look creepy.
It looks like a nightmare.
A little nothing legs.
There was a thing that was in North
America millions of years ago.
At least 1 million,
I think they were called terror birds.
Ah,
oh creepy.
That thing is terror birds.
They were an enormous seven feet tall,
uh,
enormous birds and some of them were
even bigger than that.
That we're a predatory.
They're flightless birds to lived in
North America.
Huge.
Really?
Yeah,
like a big foot size bird that would
probably be eat people shine huge beats
like beats.
It'll literally consume half your
abdomen.
There were these freaky fucking animals,
man.
And there was a bigger one even before
that.
Like one that dwarf that too.
That was a millions of years ago.
See you find that fucking thing.
That's my favorite thing.
When they did time travel and they go
back into prehistoric times and its
opposite.
I'm like fuck,
everything here will kill me.
Everything.
God has nowhere to go.
I saw Jurassic world yesterday.
How was it?
It's fun.
There's,
there's definitely some cut the shit
moments where it doesn't make sense.
It doesn't lie,
but that's,
you have to have those to make one of
those movies.
I'm starting to appreciate movies.
I'm just dumb fun.
This is what they looked like.
Oh my gosh,
look at that fucking thing.
So that was running around,
I think it was a North American animal
to that looks like it was running up to
the car look.
So it's chasing after elk and shit but
there's look it go to the upper right
hand drawing the upper right hand one.
It shows you how big they were.
They were fucking enormous.
Oh Wow.
Way better than human.
Yeah.
And then there was ones that were even
bigger than that.
Those are the two biggest ones.
I liked this one because they put the
human like the outline of the human.
But he's holding a machine gun.
Fire them off.
She imagined that thing run.
Even if you had a machine gun and you'd
be like,
Ooh,
you got an and running.
Yeah.
Look how many of them there were
different kinds of enormous birds that
giant ostriches and shit.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
There,
I mean,
that fucking thing.
The really big one that's in the
foreground with that reddish beak.
What a fucking creepy thing that would
be.
If you're walking through a field and
you saw this nine foot plus tall freaky
ass bird staring at you,
it doesn't even fly.
It's just a,
it's just an armless eating machine.
I mean,
you can call it a bird,
but they can't fly.
They have any wings.
Really.
They're weird.
They have giant talents.
What they are as a fucking dinosaur.
Right.
There's some weird ass dinosaur that
made it to a 2018 you know?
That's like a big theory.
It's a big thing.
It's being debated amongst the birds are
dinosaurs.
Yeah.
They really think that it's quite
possible that a lot of those dinosaurs
had feathers.
Yeah.
I became birds.
They are birds.
Yeah.
Like all over their body.
They were like,
when we look at a t rex,
he might've been covered in feathers.
Oh,
that would've been cool.
Yeah,
we don't know.
They know.
Some of them definitely were though.
They're finding some of them covered in
feathers.
These mikes are great.
They're not bad.
It's still picks you up like way back.
Little
pretty good,
but not,
it doesn't pick up too much bullshit in
the background.
We've tried other ones that like pick up
shit in the background too much.
Like if you moved some things over here
it would be too loud.
Yeah,
it's,
some of them are Jamie,
you can explain what are the ones that
are like,
they literally pick up every sound in
the room,
the pickup pattern and whatnot at the
preamp on.
This isn't up very loud.
Oh,
it's up loud,
but it's not.
So yeah,
this,
this Mike needs a preamp because it has
a very low nominal level.
If you don't know what that means at
all.
I am in podcasting and I have no idea
what you're talking about.
Famous dropping some audio knowledge.
I just want a bike to be able to do the
thing where you talk,
like you're in a car driving by a line
where you're like,
hey everybody,
maybe later we'll go to the store and
then we'll get that sound.
Does that sound I supposed to sound like
the jobs off debt with a pan.
I could do that right now actually.
Oh really?
Yeah,
but,
but you'd have to do that with software.
You wouldn't be doing that with just the
microphone.
We and not with just the microphone.
That's the worst.
Where do you think you would fucking
getting the line and you'd like yell
something at them,
but then when you're in the line,
do you realize all you hear is yeah,
definitely.
Yeah.
It's a Phoenix Shit.
What'd he say?
You'd have to actually get your body out
the window and yell.
[inaudible] otherwise it sounds just
coming out in a weird way.
We're boxy.
Pattern.
You remember dirty work,
dirty word?
Um,
yeah.
With form and are already already.
Yeah.
He does that to a lie to you.
I can move them.
He moves the line already and then he
just pulls over.
He's like,
I was,
uh,
I supposed to keep driving.
Sorry.
Everybody.
Did you see the pictures have already
been waltzing already?
Haven't seen him around.
His nose is all fucked up and it's caved
in it.
Well,
I guess he snorted something and he got
an infection.
A vague sense knows was huge.
It was weird.
Yeah,
it's pretty big.
It's like,
wow.
Yeah.
Look at that right there.
Oh yeah,
that one.
Yeah.
What is going with the Rd legs?
Notes?
Yeah.
Something's happening with such a good
guy.
He's a great,
he's a really good pool player.
Is it really?
I can be.
He's real good.
He's more than anybody like refused to
accept that he's famous,
so he just like walks around normal and
then people will start barking.
I was like,
oh yeah,
they kind of like goes away.
But like he just goes in a normal
environments all the time.
He's a good dude.
Really is really good guy.
He is not making 20,
20.
I don't think so.
No Way.
He has no,
no desire to quit.
He's just,
he's riding it out.
Did he quit for a while?
They,
I think every once in a while.
I don't really know.
I think every once in a while,
like he gets cleaned from ray,
but it's like he doesn't really white,
just wants to cut,
pull it back a little.
Sometimes he's never gonna be one of
those guys like,
yeah,
I haven't touched this stuff in five
years.
Yeah.
I don't think he's interested in that.
He's enjoying himself.
That's what Mitch Hedberg said before he
died.
Apparently they're trying to get them to
clean up.
He's like,
I'm not doing shit.
I like it.
Yeah.
It's like when you tell people quit
smoking,
like,
why I'm not desiring quitting.
Right.
You guys are,
yeah.
That's a hard pill for people to swallow
that don't do it.
Yeah.
You know,
like,
oh yeah,
just quit.
You should just quit.
Do when you see those gacked out people
on the sidewalk in New York,
you know,
just fucking standing up,
those doubt or something like that.
Or just like pat,
you know,
nodding off in their own whatever tech
day time you're like,
wow,
they're fucked up.
But now that I've done enough drugs,
you realize like loving it right now
they are having the best time.
They're peaking.
It looks Shitty,
but the pig and when they come to with
shitting their pants and nowhere where
to go.
All right.
The best but can superbowl tweaking.
Yeah.
Their experience is amazing.
They're,
they're a here in Lucy,
in the sky with diamonds.
Oh God.
Sam The sky
and then just sitting there.
Oh,
just trippin.
forgot to tell you this.
Well,
so when I was,
I was having some pretty good thoughts
on this.
Acid watches from different paths of the
killers by the way,
fucking killed him.
Hmm.
Um,
sorry.
You see stuff in like when you're out
there,
it's like a dog.
So a truth,
I call them universal truths where you
just like,
yes,
that is real.
That is right.
100%.
And it's hard to bring that shit back
into this realm,
you know,
to understand it and trying to get us
kicked off of youtube that it's passing
car.
So it's hard when you come back to be
like,
oh,
I saw the truth of something and then
it's like you can't express it.
And when people come back,
when they're around you,
they say something and you're like,
what?
And they're like,
they realize I get frustrated.
They're not saying it right.
Yeah.
And then it's slowly going away.
So when I was there in that place,
sometimes I try to remember like when
you get back,
say this to this person,
so that state told me to tell you m and
m is one of the real estate amps is
okay.
I'm not going to argue with it.
I don't know what exactly,
but it was like,
does that could be a funny bit,
dude,
this is a funny bit in there,
like about how like some things are just
in the moment.
They seem so profound.
So rob,
you're like,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
M and ms one of the real MCS.
Why I would agree with that.
Oh,
so he's very,
very real.
It seems fairly real.
Yeah.
Right.
Yeah,
and as I heard it,
I was like,
that's going to sound dumb in the real
world.
But I was like,
all right.
What did you think of that?
B e t music awards thing he did where he
was like freestyle,
right?
Well,
no,
some people liked it.
Some people liked it.
Did they?
The anti trump thing.
Everybody gets old.
It was interested.
It's good old.
Yeah.
But he was,
no,
he was angry and he had all of his
friends around him.
Yeah.
That was the weird thing.
Like why are all those dudes just
standing around kissing?
No,
those,
they're
all just hanging around these cars like
in a circle.
They're all waiting while eminem wraps.
So he's got like all these,
that's what they,
it's the rap cypher.
That's what they all take turns.
Oh really?
They all did it.
Does that mean I'm just turn?
Yeah,
but where's the other ones?
The videos.
The other guys too.
My name is far better.
One guy steps forward.
I need to understand rap culture better.
Definitely.
Almost said rape culture,
b e t awards show.
Oh,
that's how they do it.
They did at the bet awards show.
It's like a thing that they find it a
fucking parking lot.
Parking lot,
but the various different groups have
different labels maybe would have taken
that put up their own guys.
It's called keeping it street.
Really interesting actually are not
street God,
you don't know anything.
That's why they had to tell you that m
two m and m's,
one of the real estate MCS I already
knew.
He keeps it street.
But uh,
that thing was,
it was interesting.
It's like when people,
you know,
when you create this big explosion,
this attack on someone from someplace,
that's always fascinating to me to watch
that go down.
Like,
what's someone doing here?
Like what,
what's happening here?
What's,
what are you,
what is your sport?
What's your take on it?
It wasn't as best work.
Right,
right.
You know,
I mean,
I think he's an amazing rapper.
Like some of his shit from the past is
fucking incredible freestyle.
Well first of all,
I'm not feeling that gold chain.
Jamie's like put that three styles
anymore.
It's not freestyle,
it's just not,
I don't even hear it was freestyle.
Things are free.
I feel like you write up a lot of those.
Oh,
you got good again,
practice to man.
I liked the Cadillac in the back.
I'll tell you that I got a boner for
lack on the right.
Yeah.
That looks like,
what is that like a 70 something
cadillac that things fucking beautiful.
Oh,
I love those things.
I don't give a fuck about this rap,
but that Cadillac is the shit.
I got a boner for old cars,
dude.
I'm one of those old dudes that likes
old music and old cars.
Do you see,
um,
that that rap would,
it's like a,
I forgot who it was,
but it was like saying from the white
point of view about what the form of
black people and then from a black point
of view as far with white people,
video is somebody like lips.
I can pretty well something,
I'm like redneck dude.
It's like black people always complained
about this and this and then it goes
back.
Hmm.
I forgot who it is,
young something.
But the problem with black people and
white people is that people say black
people and white just people.
Yeah.
Instead of just people.
I was watching this video,
it's annoying video of this lady calling
the cops and this little eight year old
black girl who's selling water,
they've seen it viral viral video,
supposed to sell water.
She's calling the fucking police.
She St selling water without a permit
and her mom videotapes her and puts it
up and makes it viral.
And that's one of those videos where
it's everything's in the right place.
The white lady is overweight.
She's just angry looking like you're
overweight white lady.
The little black girl is cute as a
button.
The mom is uh,
the mom is talking to where in a way
that's like not too aggressive.
She goes,
she out here calling the police on a
little girl trying to sell water.
We see you boo.
Like she's not being horrible and
everything just fell into place to this
like perfect example of like what's
happening here?
Like is this racism or is this someone
who's just just complains about
everything,
which she be doing that for an eight
year old little.
I don't know.
That's why I hear the argument a lot of
like you wouldn't do this if it was a
man you want to be.
This was a woman you want to go,
this was black.
But it's like you're not basing on what
the next set of,
it's just like one example for us.
One example,
well you're not pro,
there's no proof.
You wouldn't have done that eight year
old White Hills Chamber of commerce.
And whenever somebody wanted to do
seeding,
like,
like sidewalk seating,
they had to get through,
but all it would take is one housewife
from the area to get a stick up their
ass about the rules and say no,
no.
And then it'll be done by 8:00
PM there won't be any hurt on the,
on the people around us when lean up.
And if she goes no,
that,
it's like 24 more hoops to jump,
you know?
And it's just because he's housewives
have nothing to do better than new
enforce rules.
So it could be that could be fucked.
These black kids.
I don't,
I don't have any idea.
She was on the um,
on an interview talking about it,
which is a terrible idea by the way.
The white lady and she put all this
makeup on and everything,
which is also a terrible,
but mimi from drew carey show,
it was just not good.
Like,
oh my God.
And went with it.
You carry right.
I forgot about her.
Um,
but the whole thing was she was saying
that she was working and that she had
the window open.
The little girl was shouting and
screaming.
She was trying to make it look bad as
possible.
Yes.
She was a victim and she said she
apologized to both the little girl and
the mom,
but they won't accept her apology,
which is like,
okay,
well,
you know,
there's nothing wrong with accepting
someone's apology.
Clearly she shouldn't have done that.
Like he shouldn't tell a little eight
year old and not sell water on a hot
day.
Who gives a fuck?
Like that doesn't make any [inaudible]
just going,
hey,
come on guys.
It's all screen by my window.
Yeah,
like maybe she was saying that it was a
hot day and so she had her window rolled
down.
The kid was screaming,
but apparently she didn't talk to them.
She didn't talk to the kid and she
didn't talk to the mom.
It's just called the police went outside
a so antisocial.
Just go straight to like someone to deal
with it instead of just like,
hey.
It's like when you get a note in your
apartment door saying something,
it's like just or the front door.
You're like,
just come to my apartment.
Knock.
Just ask once.
Just try it humanity once and then go to
the other step.
So they compared her with this white
chick hit called on Chicago police on
the barbecue and did the same person.
Not really,
but yes,
it's like that.
She's doubling down.
That's just going forward.
They look so similar man.
Like in the way the shape of their body.
Housewife,
it's,
Yep,
it's Adelaide's white housewife.
It's a fucking Shitty,
the worst position to be in in the
world.
There's definitely work to do there.
Look,
come on.
Come on.
Look at the two of them together.
They're both on the phone with these
like sexually ambiguous forms,
like you know that that's a woman,
but you know both of them there,
they're overweight and it's just weird.
It's weird.
They're like,
clearly you see that I'm going to go out
on a limb.
I don't think most,
I will say most people that are shaped
like that don't feel good.
I don't feel good.
They don't feel good right there.
They're upset at stuff.
They ever,
ever have somebody screaming about
something like,
you're not supposed to set waters here,
but there's meet them with like,
what happened to you?
What are you still angry but you're
supposed to.
I was like,
sure.
Okay,
I'll get to that.
So why are you so mad selling water
without a permit?
I got a discussion with someone at
twitter way back about that guy,
Michael Brown.
I can't breathe.
What's that?
Michael Brown?
Eric Garner was Eric Garner.
Yeah.
And somebody is like,
yeah.
What's your understand is I have a
business and like I sell it.
Let's say I sell cigarettes.
I'm somebody undercutting me with no
permits right outside that really hurts
my business.
And I was like,
okay,
sure,
I'll give you that.
Do you think the punishment for that
should be choking someone?
Maybe till I can't breathe.
And he's like,
oh no,
no.
That's too much of a punishment.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Well here's the problem with that.
The official version of that is that he
didn't have any cigarettes on him.
They did not know he had nothing.
He had nothing.
What?
Yeah,
no,
he had nothing when they had arrested
him before for that,
but he was clean.
So all have cigarettes.
Who's telling him leave him the fuck
alone?
He's like,
y'all was out here.
Fuck with me.
Just leave me the fuck alone.
They started by wanting to frisk him and
there was for no reason.
Oh my God,
I've been sick.
It just one sentence is still too much.
It's like,
just give me the ticket bit.
Yes,
they shouldn't touch them.
I mean,
and he wasn't a violent guy,
wasn't like,
like threatening them and some sort of a
way.
And,
and then they tried to say that it
wasn't a chokehold pitch.
Let me put you in that.
Did I pass by the two cops that I wanted
to?
Uh,
they were,
one was sec right after that in New York
was like,
that's not a choke hold.
And I want,
I wanted to stop and go,
actually I'm friends with an expert on
the subject and he does say that
chocolate chip called a choking to death
like that.
Yeah.
I will choke you to death with that.
How's that underneath clothes?
And he's got his hands grip that is like
the same vr.
It's a backwards version of what you
would call it.
A Marcello Garcia Guillotine,
which means like there's certain guys
that are really good at getting the
blade of the forum across your
esophagus.
It's very painful.
And um,
like some of like Amal Easton taught me
how to do this and shout out to boulder,
Colorado,
a Amal Easton is a Jujitsu coach and
he's got a fantastic guillotine.
And one of the things about his
guillotine is he knows how to get that
blade of that bolt right into your
esophagus.
It's horrific.
It feels terrible.
And they do it like with the high
elbows,
he can't escape it.
It's and it,
it's an immediate feeling.
That guy has his forearm right across
that guys throat.
Yeah.
There's no doubt about it.
If I'm holding that like that and I'm
clan,
he has his hands clasped together.
Can you make it a little bigger so I can
see you and this is how right hand
resist like easy,
but you could still choke someone out
even if it's,
hey,
I can't tell if his hands are connected.
I think they are.
It looks like he's got a man inside.
His hair garners a hundred percent a
hundred percent and and his arms behind
his too.
But the point
is the guy was choking him.
The way he's doing that,
you could choke a guy like that with one
arm.
You don't even have to have that right
arm in play.
If he's got that left arm underneath the
neck like that.
All his dude's hooked the the back of
the head or the shoulder rather.
The traps you if you want your arms
along from San Jose,
he got somebody on a one shields.
Yeah.
Jake.
Do anybody like that?
Tito Ortiz did that,
uh,
in the UFC before he choke somebody out
with a one armed t t um,
Luke rockhold did.
It's a Michael Bisping.
He got him in a mounted a one armed a
guillotine.
I mean,
here's the problem.
Why don't the other cops that would go,
hey,
tell me that's enough.
Yeah.
Listen man,
that's a God damn choke hold.
I know.
Choke holds.
I commentate him on for a fucking
living.
That's chokehold and if you don't think
it's a choke hold,
let me put you in it.
Let me put you in it and to see how long
you last.
What's it fucking choke hold?
Have you been a lot of big up here?
That guy's been calling you out.
Have you talked about it?
Alex Jones?
No.
Fighter.
Which one?
Oh,
Colby.
Colby is funny man.
I know.
Colby.
And I also know very well one of colby
is really good friends is my friend Cam
Haines.
They'll really,
they're live in the same town.
Why is this fine with you?
Cause he's Coz it's good.
It's good.
You're really got to choose to be heal
or hero.
And I would always go,
he'll,
he's all healed.
Ah,
it's so much more fun.
Go.
He'll,
you know what's really hilarious?
Chael Sonnen's mad that I talked about
what he does that I know that I talked
about with colby does.
I go,
he's having fun.
he's playing up the role of the villain
and he's selling papers cause you're
cutting away the fourth wall to the
business.
It's so ridiculous.
Meanwhile,
he's given up the secrets of the
business by talking about me giving up
the secrets of the business.
It's the dumbest shit of all time.
I can't tell if it's a work.
I can't tell if what he's doing he's
doing,
if he's fake upset.
There was a point where [inaudible] was
the best trash talker in sports ever.
Yeah,
no,
he was phenomenal.
He still is.
But the idea that you bring up the trash
on the doctor gone.
It's thunder.
When Anderson Silva walks in,
it sounds like a mouse pissing on
cotton.
It's like,
what the fuck?
I've never lost a fight in my lap.
I've never lost a route of,
I've never lost one second of one fight
in my love life and that.
Then he's like,
what about here?
Where you're going to fucking stop.
Didn't matter.
He just kept going.
I loved it.
It was beautiful.
He's a smart guy but he's also getting
us to talk about it and getting us to
talk about his show,
which I'll give him a plug right now
cause I'm sure it's great.
He's an Ariel Helwani and Chell son and
have a new show called Ariel in the bad
guy and you got to get that Espn Kay.
He's the bad guy.
He's great at it,
is great at us and he ranted and raved
about us for like 10 minutes and then he
goes and then Brendan,
he responded and he came back with
another 20 minutes.
You don't ever talk about the business.
First of all have to,
because my job is to what I see,
my job is not ness.
I,
even when I'm promoting things,
if I'm promoting things,
I'm calling what I see.
If I say Francis and Ghana is the most
terrifying heavyweight contender ever,
I say that because that's what I see.
I see him put Alistair overeem into
fucking orbitz's side of it.
So you're just talking about the
fighting part.
That's what you're experts that I talk
about.
Whatever I want to talk about.
Listen,
here's the deal.
Here's what you stick to.
Fighting a promoting and let
intelligence,
uh,
leave that here too intelligent people.
You're out of your class.
Fucking deal with it.
Whoa,
uneducated.
You're a high school dropout and you
know it.
You go to trash talk and that's it.
I don't think he's calling with your
life.
I think he graduated from college.
No,
he didn't.
He fucking dropped out of high school
early,
like sophomore year.
No.
That guy's dumb,
bro.
Yeah.
Son is gone.
Are you sure?
Yeah.
Have you ever talked to him?
Yes.
He Ain't told you two points above
retarded.
Oh,
what are the points?
What points do you get when you got a
real issue line that they have medically
is like,
if you are barely retarded,
you're still not fuck really retarded,
but I should be more politically correct
with our use of that word.
Mentally retarded.
You're a terrible trans and trans.
Start it all.
You can't say that.
You can't say that it's illegal.
It's like jazz.
It's hard.
It depending on who is president,
you'll get arrested for that to come in
for you.
I like chill.
I like what he does.
I have to talk about the fact that
someone's talking shit to build up,
but it doesn't stop someone from talking
shit.
It also makes it more fun to watch.
I know what the fuck it is and I like
it.
People are going to like it.
It makes it more interesting.
It makes it look Hofeld.
Dos Anjos went into that octagon with
the weight of not just fighting colby
with his considerable skillset because
Colby beat him from fucking what round
one to round five.
Most rounds were controlled by colbys
pressure.
Most moments dos Anjos,
he's a killer.
He had some very good moments in the
first round,
but colby overwhelmed them.
There's no doubt about that.
So he has skill on top of that.
But part of what was interesting about
it was Hockfield dos Anjos came into
there with the weight of all the shit
that colby had been talking.
That stuff you carry that man all doe
carrots.
What Aldo was with a led vest.
He's jumped in,
but do we need to do like a leg?
He had a led vest on of the anger he
had.
He just wanted to smash conner and
conner slid out of the way and just
right away,
like,
what are you doing?
Drop the left hand on his chin.
It was,
it was one of the most artistic
expressions of shit.
Talking manifest again outside the box
behavior.
Uh,
you know,
a loss of composure.
He lost his composure.
He really did.
It was crazy for hyper aggressive and he
ran right into a perfectly place
lefthand.
But Anderson and chill had that too.
I mean,
chill.
Fuck.
He frustrated Anderson.
So frustrated more with what he was
doing in the octagon.
No saying saying first he talked crazy,
mad shit to peep for people to
appreciate shale as a fighter.
What I say is you've seen some really
good fights and his,
he's had some wins that are very good.
He'd beat rampage.
That's a big win.
But if you go back,
watch him fight nate Marquardt cause
nate Marquardt was in his prime.
He would come over from strikeforce.
He was at that time when he had a busy
just leaving strikeforce.
He went to strike force.
It became they're light.
They're a welterweight champion.
It became the one 70 over there.
He peeked tyron woodley in this crazy
fucking chaos sequence.
We blast with an elbow and hits him in
the upper cut.
It's one of the greatest Kaos sequences
of all time.
I play this for you now let me,
let me just say this,
nate Marquardt at one point in time was
one of the best,
if not the best mixed martial arts
fighter in this country has come give us
Anderson.
He never,
no,
he never found the,
the UFC during his,
his right moments in his crime.
He had already had all shit load of
fights outside the UFC by the time he
got here.
And I think he was probably a little
compromised by the time he got here.
Josh Barnett.
It's like the,
yeah,
he won the title in the UFC when he was
talking to 44.
He's the youngest ever UFC heavyweight
champion.
I'm a moron.
I mean,
that's clearly where Josh fought a bunch
at times VFC during one stint.
Um,
and he,
he got killed by Pedro.
His,
oh,
he beat randy couture for the title.
Josh was a beast,
man.
I mean,
Josh was a fucking beast.
He really was.
Um,
but so it was nate Marquardt and shale
fought nate Marquardt when nate
Marquardt was very close to his prime,
they went to war,
man.
They went to fucking war and chilled.
Nominated them until dominated them.
Yeah.
And we dominated with his wrestling is
wrestling because he talks so much shit.
And because he seemed so silly when he
says,
I've never lost us.
Second of are any around in any fight.
This is,
this is the Kaos secrets with Nick
Marquardt and Tyron.
Dude,
nate Marquardt was a fucking assassin at
one point.
Yeah.
Guys,
I know guys that trained within,
they say,
dude,
I never saw nate lose a fucking round.
He just,
it just never came together perfectly in
the UFC,
but watch this chaos sequence.
This is insane.
By the way,
he's fighting
Woodley.
Boom.
He catches him.
Watch this,
watch this elbow.
Boom.
Here comes,
oh,
this is not the sequence.
This is the sequence towards the end.
Yeah.
This is not the sequence where it was
the Kao CV.
Just get right to the Kao thought I had
it right.
Then it started over.
This was a,
by the way,
very different.
Tyron Woodley I should say too.
This is pre duke roufus.
This is tyron.
When he was just coming off of
wrestling.
Here it is.
So you heard him with that right hand
and he comes in and he catches them with
a,
with a big elbow.
This been way better.
If it was just cued up to the chaos,
isn't there just the chaos sequence?
Because I know I've seen it like just as
a,
a clip on youtube.
Just scoot ahead a little.
Yeah,
right there.
Yeah.
Named mark was great for a while.
Dude.
I'm telling you.
So this fight,
boom,
look at this.
Boom,
boom.
Come on man.
That's video game.
Play that back.
Gosh,
that's video game shit.
That's video game shit.
Every one.
And again,
this is tyron Woodley.
He's a fucking stud.
Hello all the way down.
That shit is insane.
That's an insane Kao.
So chail dominated that dude and
dominated him when he was in this era.
Tell me,
what year was this fight and what year
was [inaudible] fight against them in
the UFC?
So chill has some serious skill too,
particularly with his wrestling.
So people,
you know,
they,
he,
but the trash talking was why he became
famous.
It wasn't just that,
it was,
no,
it was a trash talker.
That's when I became aware of Google,
nate Marquardt.
Um,
uh,
his lead,
I mean,
was,
was like nothing I'd ever seen.
Anderson,
I thought you absolutely suck.
I mean,
we saw a bunch of Anderson fights and we
saw a bunch of pipe before that,
but it was never,
it was never that.
The bathroom was like,
I'm going to take him down and beat him.
So the Tyron Woodley fight was in 2012
and when did he fight?
Chael Sonnen was before that.
See that's how good chell son and was he
beat that two years before,
before he went over to strike force,
it became the welterweight champion.
So you,
he fought him in his absolute prime and
dominated them.
He could people,
this is,
this is nate Marquardt duty fought.
Everybody lists her Silva.
Jeremy Horn.
Now Damien Maia.
Which one punch?
Remembering in Maya Chael Sonnen.
He got lit up by Anderson though.
Cardo Meda.
Fuck this.
Who Shall Cami Anderson ground and
pounded him,
I think nate.
Nate,
nate.
Honestly I feel like nate at one 70 was
that as best?
Yeah,
you t k o to me grounded.
Pounded him,
I believe at one seven he was at his
best like can you see him at the time?
Would they fight because he was big,
but he wasn't too big.
He wasn't too bulky and he was a,
he was a very powerful guy for that
weight class.
If you could kept it that way.
Class.
Damn.
He's lost a lot.
He lost a lot of fights.
Yeah,
that's the problem.
And I think he's retiring now,
but um,
he's like two and six foot.
My point was it doesn't take anything
away from the skill of the guy when
you're talking about his shit talking.
It's fun.
It's a fun aspect of what it is that you
have to talk about and the activities
not making money off.
It is preposterous.
That's a ridiculous argument.
He was saying that,
I said that he was,
that he was doing it for pay per view
sales and he's like,
he doesn't get a penny of those paper
view sales,
but that's a ridiculous thing.
First of all,
what I'm saying,
he's a dumb guy.
Oh,
his trash talk is just from a Ba from
from an uninformed point of view.
It's great because it's like stupid
stupidly like into something.
But like he's not educated on almost any
subject other than fighter.
I think he's a smart guy.
No,
I disagree.
I talked to him.
I feel like he's very intelligent.
Yeah.
Wow.
You're a giving.
I am a Guinea harsh toward them.
My face,
when I look at all the Jews that one,
Nobel peace prizes,
Nobel Science Project,
whatever it is.
What is the Nobel Prize for science?
One by more European Jews than I think
any other race.
Is it surprising?
Isn't that true?
Yeah,
that sounds right.
Something,
any other race,
any other,
I think any other like obvious
classification.
It's never a Sicilian Italians.
You know the word's out,
man.
We,
yeah,
we're smart.
Why are you guys smarter?
What is that about?
I think it's just honestly like just
stuff jimmy the Greek was talking about,
but like in a positive way.
Just we're just our brains.
We're just,
we've inner,
first of all,
okay.
Were bred for that.
We don't have any outside genes.
Right.
So like,
you know how some dogs are super like
loyal bread.
Yeah.
Or we're just intelligence.
Everything else was falling apart.
It might be something to that.
Why is it racist to say,
why is it racist?
I used to say we're smarter.
It's crazy to say something is less
smart.
Less.
Yeah,
but no,
we're the smartest ones.
Maybe second,
maybe the Chinese guy you beat,
well,
you know Asians.
This is what's really crazy.
Yeah.
There's a real issue right now with
Asians and university enrollments,
particularly in Harvard.
They discriminate against Asians because
so many apply because so many are
kicking ass.
Yeah.
To get them out of there.
There's,
there's like real talk about how this is
crazy because Asian people for bye,
right?
This is a generalization and try not to
be racist,
but generally speaking,
Asian students are known as working very
hard and they're very dedicated and
they're very successful and the
representation is overwhelming in terms
of their numbers in the population and
they're killing it,
killing it,
and because of that and their,
their mindset is to just work really
hard.
It's not to protest things and not to
shut things down.
It's just creating the library.
They're all those protests.
There was in the library,
some of the Indians.
While this is all happening.
I'm not saying that they're not socially
conscious,
but while this is all happening,
they're not protesting it the way may be
other groups that felt marginalized,
whether it's people of color or trans
people or gay people,
whatever it is,
don't feel represented or discriminated
against.
They would be shutting down,
you know,
conferences and yelling down speakers
and shouting out in the hallway.
But the Asians,
the whole reason why they kick ass cause
cause they don't spend any time on petty
bullshit.
He's like get done.
So because of that,
the Harvard,
Harvard fucking Harvard is saying,
Hey,
we're going to be racist against you
cause we know you're not going to
complain.
Well wow.
What?
Look at this.
Let's pull this up.
Pull this up Jamie.
I want you to pull up Asian students
harder to get into Harvard lawsuit.
That's crazy.
It's crazy.
And it's not a small amount.
They're discriminating by,
they're making their grades considerably
higher in order to gain acceptance.
Really?
Yes.
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean it's all because of a natural
breakdown of different races.
You can't,
you can't slow one down.
Harvard would have less less productive
graduates.
It doesn't make any sense.
It's a crazy way of thinking,
but it's all in this idea of diversity,
like instead treating people as
individuals instead of just saying human
beings.
You have to have each class represented
by a certain amount of people,
but it's not anti [inaudible].
It's like it's not a racist idea to want
everybody to be treated as one.
It's just,
it can be done with an eye on avoiding
all possible racism.
It can be done to treat people purely as
individuals.
Here's the worst way that can ever be
done.
The worst way because you tell them most
successful people were complaining the
least that they have to work harder.
You are getting fucked by your genes.
You the people in your past and your
group,
your little gene pool to good doing too
good in schools so we don't make it
harder than it is from my kids.
That's nuts.
Literally what people are doing there
too,
because if they didn't harp,
it wouldn't be like all Asians,
Asians,
it'd be dominating and it the very
reason why they think they can get away
with this lawsuit accuses Harvard have
discriminated against Asian American
applicants in personal ratings,
personal writings.
I don't know what it is,
man.
They're making it more difficult.
It says students for fair admissions has
accused Harvard of intentionally
discriminating against Asian American
applicants by limiting their admissions
numbers so they're limiting the numbers.
I this many agents and by the way,
that's super hard for like let's say
like Vietnamese or not the Chinese or
Japanese Craig,
you know we should say we don't know if
this is true.
We should say,
you know,
just to be really clear,
this is a lawsuit.
We don't know if this is true,
but this is the argument and this is the
argument that many,
many,
many people have made.
Now,
I haven't really personally researched
this,
but I know a lot of like legitimate
intellectuals,
it brought this up and debates and
conversations and they're saying,
look,
this is an issue.
This is essentially,
this is sanctioned racism against one
group because they're too effective.
So you're limiting the number of your
sag web where we're trying to get more
of an emphasis on like extra curriculars
in or out based on being Asian or based
on being European.
That's crazy.
You should get in or out by you having
merit and you being a a worthy student
and difficult schools like Harvard or
supposed to be difficult and if the
cream of the crop all comes from Asia,
shouldn't we look at what the fuck we're
doing here that we can't compete with
them?
I mean,
what is it?
Wow there.
Do we want Asian students?
Do we want to compete with them?
I mean,
is it too much or they were requiring
too much of their life to be successful.
What?
Their style,
their schoolwork.
I mean,
yeah.
That's the thing too.
If you're going to want a normal life,
you want to look up your normal life
too.
If you're going through college and
everything you're doing all day is
studying and you literally,
you might have like some fucking shitty
part job somewhere to make some money
for food and then you're studying more,
right?
Maybe you have a part time job.
A lot of people don't.
So if you think about all that topic,
if I want for my kids,
that's a crazy life.
No way you,
and especially with some of the things
are just for four years.
Some of the things,
it's not that anything you're really
interested in,
but you have to get it on.
You have to be,
you know,
you have to have a fully balanced
education,
so you have to take classes you're not
even remotely interested in.
You have to do it.
And it's this one way and this is how we
can assure that you have enough
knowledge that we can give you a piece
of paper that says you have a degree.
I mean an Asians or Kkr as well.
That's the game.
Okay.
Within those roles.
Well,
we'll just going to work 20 hours a
dude,
I,
my friend,
junk sick.
I've think I've told you about him
before.
He was a u s national taekwondo team
member when I was like,
hmm,
what is this junk sec,
Indonesia Chang.
He's Korean.
He was going through his fucking
residency.
He was going to be a doctor going
through his residency and training for
the national team and he was running
stairs,
running stairs in the school in between
studying,
he would do studying the nude run the
stairs.
You got to hold the guy got back,
dude.
You couldn't hold him back.
He slept four hours a night.
That if that's true,
that's,
that's the same shit is like he was
always tired.
Yeah.
He's always tired because he works hard.
He wouldn't give a fuck.
He was always tired.
He would just show up exhausted and kick
ass.
Wow.
And he wasn't physically talented
either.
This guy made it to the,
to the nationals and he became a
national champion and he wasn't even
like really,
really physically talented.
It wasn't like some freak athlete that
just move super fast.
You can,
he's just fucking unbelievably smart,
unbelievably hard worker.
But I saw the way that guy was living as
he was like I was a couple of years
younger than him and he was going
through his residency and training and
doing all this crazy shit at the same
time and I was,
I was like,
I'm exhausted just watching you.
Like I can't see how this could be worth
it to do all those things.
Did you one of those things?
Maybe that's what I want to do.
I want to do one of those things,
but you're doing two of those things.
He was doing what I was doing and then
on top of it and more and way more,
way more,
he was doing schoolwork done was
delivering newspapers and shit.
If that's happening,
they're just saying like,
it's the same thing as like making it so
white people get ahead.
It's crazy.
It's like you could as loitering laws,
now you're arrested if you don't have a
job,
but that's,
this is where you could realize that all
this stuff is crazy.
You're,
you're,
you're being racist against a minority
and you think it's okay because they
kicked so much ass because there are
powerful.
So were like,
we can,
we can take them down south.
It's literally racist because if you're
saying you can only have a certain
number of these people in there,
it's crazy.
That's racist.
It's gotta be to,
to,
to say,
no,
we're trying to keep a diverse
population so you're not a
representative population of the best of
the best then.
I mean,
they should take off any of their names
off of their applications or something
like that and just were like,
let's see what they got.
Yeah.
But I guess they'd probably judge you
based on many things.
Right.
You know,
they try that for the old daily show
with Jon Stewart.
Just take the names off the application.
We don't want to see your names just for
your writing sample.
Oh,
that's smart.
Yeah.
That's smart.
Well,
here's what happened though.
The hired only white males,
goddammit.
Yeah.
And the John Stewart was like,
okay,
I guess we're going in blind is not
enough.
I guess we fucked up.
He didn't even say like,
well that just shows it's not our fault.
That's just fucking randomly we had
eight people and they happen to be white
dudes.
Here's the thing though,
if you had movers,
okay,
and you wanted to move furniture and you
tested people for moving furniture,
is it okay to hire all men?
Yeah,
it's okay.
Why?
Because they're physically stronger
physically right now.
Um,
is it okay to hire someone who you think
is going to be the best at the job or do
you have to have a certain amount of
women so you wouldn't expect it from
something physical,
like a moving company,
but why should it be mandatory for
something like a creative thing?
Well,
it's different a little bit because no
one except the client is appreciating
the movers,
right?
It's just like if I'm hiring,
I'm the only one who have to deal with
it.
Like safe.
You were saved,
you were,
um,
doing a show like a woman's show,
a woman's comedy show.
Okay.
And what am I,
am I may know or am I a woman?
You'd have to be a woman,
I guess.
Okay,
go ahead and you want,
you are a female executive producer and
you want to have like a female voice to
it.
So you wanted to is hire some really
funny chicks and what guy's gonna?
I know,
obviously it happens way,
way,
way more often the opposite way where
women get discriminated against but what
guy is going to say no,
fuck that.
I want a part of this.
Oh right.
You know,
I should have a job here.
You should call a troll.
Troll won't be equally represented male
versus female cause that's what a lot of
people feel like when it comes to men
and women.
Like someone was telling bird on his
podcast that the comedy store should be
half a minute.
I know that lady just,
she has no idea what American comedy is
all about.
La.
Yeah.
She's speaking in an uninformed way.
The white shell does a lot.
I mean it's ridiculous,
dude.
It's not a joke.
He's just not that smart.
You all get tell that whatever.
But this one was the same as jail where
she was like uninformed.
They just going full bore and she wasn't
doing to promote anything.
She was just doing it because she
thought it was right,
but it's like,
oh,
you don't really understand how this
works.
There's a process or it's like,
I saw a blog once said we need more
women in,
in like hiring positions.
And it's like,
oh,
you mean the head of the comedy store?
The head of the fucking comedy cellar,
head of New York comedy club.
Uh,
uh,
Kobe are like,
there's plenty of female bookers like
you don't really know,
so I'm going to tell them that.
Then it,
then she go,
oh,
okay.
Oh,
I didn't realize that.
Well,
there's certain things that people love
to say when they've done almost no
research on what it actually is.
Yeah.
One lady had no clue.
She just goes,
I'm not getting in here.
I'm a big comic.
It must be,
it's just not causation and causality.
She goes,
it must be because of this.
I've had my agents calling.
It's like,
oh no.
I worked for Mitzi.
When agents or managers call sound like
my client in,
she'd go fuck off.
That's something that we do things here,
dude.
I got in an argument with someone about
the wage gap and they really believed
that men and women work right next to
each other doing the same job and the
woman is only making 75 cents to the
guys dollar I'm going to put out there
in no time.
This is a crazy thing to argue.
Like if you're going to argue that you
should know what that is,
you should know what that is.
Otherwise you just talking shit and
which we all do sometimes.
But you gotta be willing to say as
climate change,
I believe that that's,
I believe in that.
It's like which studies have you read?
And it's almost always no zero studies.
I like to believe this or versus
whatever.
Luckily we're not in charge of making
decisions.
People Love,
love to put these studies out.
Uh,
you'd like to tweet them out without
having even looked at them at all.
Yeah,
it's,
some of these are there.
So
there's some studies out there that
prove you everything.
Wage gap.
He was like,
so you're telling me I can get the same
list.
I'm a smart businessman who's made a
bunch of money and I can get the same
level of talent out of this woman are
better at,
well let's just say equal,
but 75% or better,
sorry ma'am,
sorry,
or or equal or probably better.
Uh,
personally,
95 cents on the dollar and I'm a smart
businessman and I'm not going to go with
the lower costs,
equal talent,
better talent.
That's,
that's how can I run a successful
business?
Making that kind of decision.
How can you,
yeah,
it would,
they would be hired at far higher rights
or you can look deeper at it and be
like,
oh,
it's just like total jobs or whatever it
is.
I can't,
I haven't raised studies,
but I just listened to people who've
have,
I think you're right.
I think there's something to that.
If they're really could hire the same
people for the same job and get a woman
who's just as good at it for 75 cents,
it's horseshit though.
They would all at higher only women.
The people who don't know what we're
talking about.
It's all based on what jobs you choose.
It's like it's not that men don't make
more money because they do the same job
and make more money at that job and the
woman does.
They do different jobs.
That's where the wage gap is.
The wage gap is in the number of hours
that men work,
the different jobs that they choose,
what they excel in.
It has nothing to do with like two
people that are both,
you know,
in the same line on a,
on an assembly line or something like
that with the same amount of time.
And they both make the same amount of
money.
Yeah.
And one or rather the male makes a
dollar a dollar for every 75 cents.
That's not how the wage gap works.
It's just different jobs.
Okay.
So hearing that information,
like I remember when I first heard it,
it was like you can either go,
fuck you.
You're just trying to fucking shit on
women or you can go,
Huh,
well let me,
I've never thought of that.
Let me look into that a little bit and
then I'll get back to you instead of
immediately reacting.
Fuck off.
Well,
people get mad like that's not what it
is.
Like,
yes,
it is what?
It is foolish if you keep arguing with
me because you don't even know what it
is.
This is a dumb conversation.
Now.
I can't argue with you when I know that
you haven't read any of the stuff that
points to these numbers.
Like,
look,
the thing is no one should be like
whatever you do,
whatever it is,
whether it is you make incredible
sculptures or you build cars,
oh,
you're a painter.
Whatever the fuck it is that you do,
no one should be able to say that you
doing this
definitely should make as much money as
doing that.
No things are worth what they're worth.
We remember Tommy Dilutes Bowler.
Yeah.
At some point he was ranked I think top
15 in the world at his sport,
which is the equivalent,
like
a,
I'm trying to even think who would be
like Carmelo Anthony and this guy,
Tom.
It dilutes at his sport made 38 grand
and and fucking and,
and Carmela makes you know 20 million.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Your sports not as popular.
It's just not as popular weight classes
in his popular whatever,
how it works.
Yeah.
That's just how it was not fucking
assault after.
Yeah.
I could see how you would want more
money.
Yeah,
sure.
Everybody does.
I get that.
But like there's certain people that
they're just,
it's a harder do that job.
And the reason why they do it is because
they know that it's more valuable so
they work hard.
Definitely get that job done.
Imagine being the fuck and CEO of a
corporation.
How much pressure would be on you all
the time being fucking Tim Cook over at
Apple.
Ah,
well that's why I don't get paid as much
as him.
Exactly.
It horrible.
Well that is the same.
This same philosophy is the reason why
women approach now,
and I say some women I should say
because there it's like super hyper
aggressive career oriented women that
work as hard or harder than men.
Maybe even harder to prove that there
was tough as demand,
but they would take the approach that
you and I would take.
I'm like,
fuck that life.
Like I'm not doing that.
Whereas it's statistically more males
push themselves by working longer and
harder hours on purpose.
Comparison,
try to succeed.
It's just a natural thing.
They're trying to win a game.
There's a competition you have is
putting points on the board.
By the way,
serialism realism is fool's game to get
into.
Personally.
I see people doing that.
My friends from high school and I'm
like,
you're wasting your life for what,
four digit number?
It's,
it's,
you're not doing anything with yourself.
The problem is men,
they get stuck in this loop of
obligation that get stuck in a loop of
children and a mortgage.
And then once you have a car and a nice
house and you know,
you maybe you want to get a boat,
dude,
you get stuck and you have all these
payments and obligations and you're not
going to wear because you have a family.
Maybe you always wanted to be a rock and
roll singer.
Yeah,
no,
and you never fucking got a chance to
get out of the blocks and you're living
your life in this angry state,
unfulfilled,
angry state.
So the advice is for the young,
the advices for young people.
The advice is for people that look at
their parents and all these other people
that are telling them what they have to
do.
Are they right or the other or is there
a fucking path out there?
If you just figure out what you really
liked to do and just only go that way,
because if you go this way and then I'm
gonna take a couple of years off and go
that way for a while and then I'm going
to like,
I'm going to go back to school and get
my degree just so I have something to
fall back on.
You just didn't,
you don't,
you didn't get any further down the
road.
You're in the same spot.
You would have been if he didn't do
shit.
You got to,
you got to go forward.
But if you something forward,
even if it's the wrong direction,
you're still getting experience doing
something.
You're finding out what it takes to
succeed and make a decision on purpose
in order to get something you think is
right.
I don't know what it's like to think
more and more people are saying no to
this old way of doing it and more be,
I want to be outdoors.
I value friendship over cash,
you know,
things like that.
Experiences over fucking money and
they're starting to go the other way and
they're starting to ask for like when
they get their jobs like okay,
I'll take this job but I want six weeks
off.
Know I'll take less money,
but I want more freedom.
People are going for that.
They are and they should.
There's no tile you,
there's no time.
There's no time.
You gotta do what you like.
You got to do stuff you enjoy.
That's why I went to New York.
I was like,
I saw 40 coming and I was like,
this seems like it's gonna be less and
less doable,
you know,
to pick up and move.
It's certain age ranges.
I know it's not,
but it just seems like that.
And so it's like,
go fucking do something you want to do.
Get going.
I want you to exercise more dude.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
I want you to your smart guy.
Yeah.
And you're,
you know,
you're in your forties you know,
you're in your forties it's super
important to keep your body healthy
because he's going to start
deteriorating.
I was talking about some of the swing to
it.
It just starts falling apart.
Man starves the stuff.
Starts Working Shitty.
See dudes,
they have,
you know what freaks me out?
It's my resolutions is here to work out
more.
I,
let's do it.
Come on,
gone up with,
after all this fucking podcast,
let's get one.
It's on the lift.
I know it's some cardio cardio machines
over here.
I have a versa climber.
You gotta do it works in a while,
but I got to do it more.
Just bike for two hours.
Just like one shot around,
but like fast.
That's why I like running some outside
doing something or running around.
It was cooler.
Yeah.
There's something to it.
I'm running around,
I see things.
I'm moving my,
yeah,
when you're on a machine you just
fucking,
unless you're listening to a good book
on tape or you're watching a television
show or something like that,
it's boring.
But when you're running you got to look
about where you're stupid.
You're high and watching like some
cartoon network Shit and running.
You could go for ever,
could he really cat?
Yeah.
Music helps you go forever.
Like there's something about having like
a bad ass song.
Like you'll,
you don't hear your own breath,
put some peaches on.
It's like you get a nice rhythm that
doesn't freak you out.
Like it freaks me out sometimes when I
hear a rhythm of me really pushing hard
cardio cause I go,
God damn,
I'm going pretty hard.
I should back off.
But when you're listening to music,
you don't even think about it.
You just keep going.
It's like a little meditative trick
occupies your mind some weird way.
It lets you to put like just a little
extra effort in.
It's pretty fun.
Plus you gotta get off your phone.
Yeah.
I can't really be all in there.
While you're doing that.
Can't be on your phone.
So it like forces you to go clear for a
little bit.
Yeah.
You can't answer calls shit when you're
on a fucking treadmill asshole.
Yeah.
People trying to talk to you.
He hear in the background and they just
like,
they're not out of breath.
They're able to talk normally.
They did that and they do nightclubs.
Right.
Wrong.
Kevin Smith's,
the first guy I ever saw that had a desk
that was a on a treadmill.
He had his desk right here.
Yeah.
When he first started losing weight,
he's gone through a few different
versions of like dieting and changing
his diet.
He,
um,
you know,
he had a heart attack.
No Way.
Really had a hard time when he was
filming of special,
he filmed two shows,
were supposed to film two shows,
filmed one and in between shows had a
fucking heart attack and uh,
just they was like,
you're having a massive heart attack.
We're taking you to the hospital queen.
Yup.
Filmings and he had the kind of heart
attack that 80% of the people that get
it die.
What?
Yeah.
It was a big one.
Total blockage.
Yeah.
Total blockage of one of his arteries.
They had to put a stent in him.
Yeah.
The whole deal.
And he's lost like a shit load of when a
Shitload,
wait,
was this recently?
Yeah,
they'll recently cause he likes to
laugh.
Yeah.
So this was when he lasts.
Lost weight.
Before when I first met him,
he was I first,
he's a sweetheart of a guy,
you know him well,
I barely know him.
I've never met him.
I just talked to my line a couple of
times,
like real quick,
super smart,
like deceptively smart.
His speeches.
He makes a comicon or fucking glorious.
No,
he's amazing.
He's an amazing guy and he's a real,
real,
like a genuine sweetheart.
So when,
uh,
when I first met him,
he had a sugar thing.
He just loved sugar.
Yeah.
He's eating a lot of candy.
He just loved eat candy.
And then when I met him a sec time,
um,
uh,
ran into him,
he decided to go on like a bunch of
juice cleanses and shit.
He was just drinking a lot of juice and
eat unhealthy food in lost up fuck load
of weight and that's when he had the uh,
the,
the treadmill thing with a laptop on
this platform.
So he would walk in and do his work.
Smart moves.
A lot of that shit's mental.
Like whenever Ralph,
he got a stomach stayed on now.
Wow.
It looks like a mouse.
Tiny little face.
Well,
beautiful tiny face.
Oh look how fat he was there.
Yeah,
he got big.
But like as soon as you lose that
weight,
you got to see a therapist cover up
something.
Yeah,
there's something,
there's something to it for sure.
You know,
it's just people get in ruts man,
because you know,
you get in ruts with your food,
you get in ruts with your behavior.
But the food one is a big one.
You know,
that kind of food is just fucking
terrible for your body.
You know,
just constantly consuming sugar.
You're putting your body into a state of
shock processing this stuff that's never
supposed to be in that form.
It's a patrice would like Chuck Two
candy bars and then pass out.
Oh whose body was trying to process it
but like,
Oh hey,
I'd be like what's going on in his body?
This is what I wanted.
The things I wanted to say to you that
one of the things that's fun about you
going to New York,
cause you've brought more New York
insults style to our conversations and
our hangs out cause la style is like way
less insulting,
but you like,
like our group text messages that we
have with Bert and topic.
My favorite thing,
it's a fucking great tax but the,
the insults to each other are hilarious
now there's so it's such New York style,
like insult comedy.
My friends in New York,
there's a guy with an la comedy.
Do your comedy is always separate before
you came there?
It's true dude.
You've made everybody more in salty.
I love it.
See the thing is,
it's fun man.
I love insulting each other.
Yeah,
it's fucking fun.
It's silly fun man.
And when someone gets you with a good
one it's like,
oh shit.
Yeah,
that's what he's like ever in La coffee
pop.
I didn't know you knew.
Who had a great point.
Wanda.
Wanda Sykes said that that was patrice.
Patrice elevated that level and she
goes,
she thinks he changed.
She really said it.
She's like,
I think he changed the frequency of that
comedy scene in a mosque that's possible
without,
when got 100% of thing started hugging
and he started the hugs in La.
Who started hugs?
The Guy who died in the car accident,
Josh.
Josh out of Mars Front.
I can't remember his name now.
Oh,
I didn't know him that well,
but he brought hugs back.
He was like,
if I'm doing that,
and it was curtis spread out in the open
mic scene.
Took your raw tall.
Well,
we always hugged sorta,
but he's like constant hugs for hellos
where it's like not weird anymore.
I didn't know of him and I independently
was hugging for hellos notion,
but I think it's great that everybody
was doing it.
But teres would hit the Rosen.
Awesome guy.
Oh yeah,
I didn't know him.
I don't even think I ever saw him.
Yeah,
I don't think I ever even saw him do
standup.
I think maybe,
see you went to clubs,
great guy.
Full of good joke,
right or no one says a bad thing about
the guy.
So Patrice would do stuff where he was
like Durosu would walk in and he would
just start making fun of neurosis,
lack of shoulders.
Oh God.
He'll be like,
you're fucking Derosa can't wear
backpacks cause they fucking fall off.
He goes,
my favorite one because you brought that
up because Joe Derosa can't have a heart
to heart with his father because I die
as much has put his hand on his shoulder
slides off.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
I was on the phone calling into opie and
anthony once and it was talking about
Anthony's gun collection and I said,
do you worry like [inaudible] con he
goes,
I'm strapped everywhere I go,
I'll go all three out your house
everywhere you go,
you're strapped.
It was,
yes,
absolutely.
I'm like,
do you ever think that like maybe you're
like manifesting this,
that like by,
by constantly having guns everywhere
you,
you're,
you're manifesting potential gun
violence and pre patrice goes rogue and
thinks that kind of shit.
Cause he,
but he's magic out,
manifest in shit about manifest it.
It's all up on that Magic House fucking
die on math.
And I was like,
oh my God,
he was so good at jumping on silly shit.
You were saying pick out like what's
your,
are you wearing no,
seriously,
what in the fuck are you wearing?
And then you just go hard,
hard,
and you just got to accept it.
It's a joke or you'll get mad or you get
bad.
You had to love it.
Dss,
his own version of that,
you know,
fuck you.
I told you that one time Diaz was
mocking me because I had a notebook,
I didn't know books and he goes,
what are you do?
We don't want that fucking notebook.
Let everybody know you're writing belly
hemingway over here.
You know as those fucking things people
don't,
right.
Like you want to let everybody know
you're right.
Get the fuck out of here with a
notebook.
He would love where you can see things
clear like that.
Taylor has this theory that I love
because anytime you hear somebody say
they're going to start or they're going
to start working
out,
who's that?
Someone who's telling you they are not
working out or are not writing.
Like what do you mean?
You can tell me I've been working out.
That's a whole separate thing.
I hear a lot what people say are about
to start doing something.
The people that are doing,
so I started using this program from my
last special,
I don't want to tell you about scrivener
views yet.
How it's set up.
It's pretty cool dude.
It's a game changer.
It's making me organize stuff and it
totally different way.
It's nice to have like a little column
to the left where I put all subject
matter.
And then to the right,
each one of those click and it'll show
you all the shit you've written on that
subject.
So you could move it around like you,
you can,
you know,
you could put your,
your set in order with something like
that.
That is,
you know,
I trying to do I need that for this.
I'm doing this out.
I'm trying to do all juice stuff.
Oh yeah.
And I do the thing about the demons and
the other dimension.
Yeah.
Nice.
I'm closing with that back and forth.
But um,
um,
yeah,
but then I had to be real conscious of
like how many like stories about two
holidays am I giving,
how many like customs am I giving,
how much my showing that I have
expertise on this.
Like I have to keep reiterating,
you know,
it'd be like 15 minutes or so,
like show something.
They're like,
no,
you should believe me because I'm,
you know,
put it back in there.
I'm not saying what's up top doesn't do
it.
You have to do a story about me and
yeshiva in Israel.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
that's right.
This guy.
But you have,
you have the deepest,
you fucking went to Israel and you were
studying how many hours a day?
14 maybe you were the literally the
Asian equivalent of the Talmud.
The Torah.
1% that gets into Harvard.
But it's just studying.
Yeah,
just text.
I know more about the shit that,
I mean anybody that I know,
Hobby Lieberman,
know some stuff and Ilan knows a little
bit.
But like,
yeah,
I was so deep in that I'm like,
and I still have friends that are deep
end that we like talk about it sometimes
and the law.
How's that?
I just,
yeah,
when my friends ask me like,
what's,
what's this customer?
I'm like,
and then I see it as it from a fresh
point of view for the first time in 20
years of like,
oh,
it's just because it represents the
watson.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
like just all the stories,
all the stories.
So like,
I'm like,
there's a story of Purim where esther
fucking,
I have to go so far back or all days,
but one of the first feminists in the
Talmud and the Torah itself was the
story of Purim where Vashti,
the queen of the king,
not Jewish,
was called to say,
hey,
come in front of my court and show your
naked body.
Well,
and she refused.
She said,
no,
I'm not doing that.
It was one of the first feminist
character spa.
She said,
no,
and she was,
she was banished and they looked for
another princess and it was this Jewish
lady that was in hiding about her
Judaism forever.
It was weird.
But anyway,
the Vashi,
we always viewed her as this great
feminist leader who could stand up for
herself.
And then recently,
um,
my sephardic Jewish friend who's deep in
there too,
he pointed,
I was like,
no,
no.
She had herpes.
She had a herpes outbreak.
She did want to show her body.
She didn't just suddenly,
that wasn't the first time because he
did more research on it.
I know you'd read all the commentary,
the Rashi and all that stuff on there
and they bring it down like
legitimately.
So some stuff he didn't really think
about and other stuff you're like,
oh,
oh.
There was a story of a,
a rabbi who,
uh,
his students were being killed by a
dragon and I read this and I'm like,
it's not supposed to be a metaphor.
Nothing in this supposed to be metaphor.
It's also means something else.
Act as metaphor,
but also be real.
So I'm like,
what's dragging?
Are you talking about his killing
students?
And I showed my rabbi this and he was
like,
all right,
this is one metaphor.
It's jerking off.
It's masturbation.
They were dying off at night and the
rabbi to kill the Dragon.
Oh,
this is the best part.
The rabbit had killed the dragon hid
under one of the students beds until the
dragging attack.
Yeah.
So I was like,
what is all this?
And he goes,
it's masturbation.
I was like,
oh,
okay.
Now it makes sense as an adult,
this makes sense to me in a normal way.
The only metaphor has to do with that.
That's so insane.
Yeah.
So now I'm starting to look at all that
shit from an adult removed point of view
with an insider's knowledge of it.
Oh,
it's so fun to do it on stage when you
can make a crowd who doesn't know
anything about Judaism,
understand it and fucking laugh at it.
Wow.
Yeah.
I'm really having fun now.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
that sounds exciting.
I want to see,
are you going up tonight?
Uh,
no.
I'm flying home tonight.
I will be back July.
Uh,
in July.
I think I'm running a previous show.
You're talking about that because we had
always talked about that like years and
years ago.
Like you should be talking about that on
stage.
I wasn't good enough.
That's it.
Right.
And so then I'm trying to cover all the
subjects too.
So it's like,
it's not,
it's weird because I'm not just like
building an hour and also I'll get
inspired by something else.
A homeless faggot,
sometimes feeding rats outside my
fucking building.
Literally loring rats into my fucking
building.
Anyways.
So there's bits like that.
I want to do,
but like this won't go in the hour.
Was it a homeless guy that was doing it
was a regular everyone's humanity after
a while.
Oh my God,
that's so fucking heartbreaking.
It's not pictures.
It's bad enough.
There's campaigns all over the city.
Put the stuff in trash cans.
We need to work together to get rid of
rats.
It's impossible.
You can lower their numbers.
You've seen the netflix thing right on
rats.
You haven't seen him?
No.
Oh,
you poor back in New York.
that's the worst part of that city.
It's in saint.
This documentary is insane.
You Watch that documentary.
You have a whole new understanding of
what you're dealing with.
There's like a little tiny army of
creatures that live amongst the New
Yorkers that outnumber the New Yorkers.
There's more,
lots a lot,
and they're smart and they showed how
you eat.
It's hard.
It is to kill them because they sent
dumb young ones out and to eat the
poison first and they die and then they
avoid it.
I'm making money.
I'm thinking of getting a cat from my
backyard.
This is it,
dude.
And it follows these exterminators cats
are good,
cancel help a lot,
but I just don't want you to hear a cat
but they've got to piss all over.
They'll piss everywhere to borrow cat
for like a week.
They'll piss all over you.
You are,
you are.
I will smell funky but they will kill a
lot of these fuckers but the thing is
maybe not going to kill them all.
You just not,
oh,
turn this off in New York has a giant
problem,
man.
I was walking down the middle of the
street,
the middle of 12th Avenue,
12th Street.
That was a bot fly.
That was in one of them.
They have all had parasites.
Tell us the story.
You were walking down the middle of the
street on the sidewalk down the middle,
straight to the seller.
Late one night,
like two 33 in the morning and this cop
pulls up behind me and was like,
we're bored and I fucking moved over.
He's like,
what do you do good on the sidewalk?
This like early I moved to New York.
It's like there's rats on the sidewalk
and I can't because I think they put the
fucking trash out.
So had the small space and the trash
starts to move and Russell and it's a
fucking rat or more and they just dart
in front of you.
What?
Hit My foot once wondering biting my
foot.
I don't text and walk anymore.
I fucking keep my eye on him at all the
time.
So I'm walking in the street and I
fucking yell,
let's level,
sorry.
I get into it when I talk about stuff,
but I yelled at this level at the cop.
I can't,
there's fucking rat.
And he was like,
oh right.
I didn't just look at it.
Let me go in the middle of the street.
Oh,
you see them move.
Something shouldn't move within.
It does.
He's like fucking ivy vine by the store
full of rat.
They just start moving.
I really feel like you're tripping on
shrooms.
Yeah,
it's creepy.
That little viney.
That's a creepy as vine.
Anyway,
so I bits like that,
that I put aside.
I do sometimes,
but the rest is like,
I got to cover this hour.
I could cover all the deets.
I can't leave anything out.
It can't leave anything out.
So it's like,
yeah,
that shit sounds perfect for like how
much to build in.
Yeah,
you a,
we always talked about that stuff,
but it's cool now that you,
yeah,
I'm a little bit,
I'm a little better as a comic 10 years
later.
Well,
you know,
I think it's also learning how to write
things and I'm putting them in order.
You know how to move stuff around and
how to set it up when you're talking
about something that's that crazy.
What do you think of it now?
Like now that you know so much about it
and you've been an whatever you would
consider yourself agnostic or an atheist
for solar,
what do you think it originally was?
What do you mean?
Like what started all this religious
writings and teachings?
What do you,
what do you think they were?
Do you think that humanity meets people?
Like the tour of the town would,
yeah,
it was a way to keep your group going
and then you make laws and how to live
inside your group.
So it's just a section of laws really is
how we're in the be.
How'd they agree?
Agreed that this,
well the [inaudible] is really
interesting because they take this,
I don't know if ever told you this,
the high faith they take the
similarities between all religions like
do not kill is almost in all of them.
So they go,
that must be a truth straight from God.
And maybe the churches sort of
disseminated,
made him weird.
Oh yeah.
The church is what?
Like you like molded those towards your
own like uh,
population.
So like Christians,
the fucking one of some of the weakest
ones.
So they can't eat meat the whole lent.
And they go,
well we don't like that.
fucking,
how about just let me know Friday?
And they go,
all right,
well except that for awhile and these
fucking weak ass nonreligious people.
And they go,
well that's true.
How about I just give up something?
And the,
the church,
it's like,
well,
either we're going to lose you or we'll
give in some of them there's no Gif.
They're just like,
this is the rule right there near out,
right?
Yeah.
Look,
some of them changed holidays and still
you do it to control your own population
with laws to help you.
I mean,
don't kill,
it helps you live as a society so you
can like be okay with each other.
It's a high takes the similarities in
all of them and so like don't kill the
story of the flood.
That's a real similar thing that lots of
religions,
so that must be a real thing that
happened and then the the don't eat pig
is like nat,
that's just a Jew thing.
Don't worry about that.
I think that's a trick of gnosis thing.
That's not the,
yeah,
the origin maybe.
Yeah.
I think that people were dying from it
and also the shellfish thing because of
red tide,
they go if they didn't know when to
accurately predict,
you know,
cer,
certain times of the year,
shellfish are absolutely toxic.
Oh really?
Yeah.
It's called.
I don't know when it is,
when I always wanted to know when it is.
But you can't get like clams and mussels
from certain beaches during certain
times of the year.
You can't cause it's tower and humanity.
That's why I could have started for
sure.
For sure.
No rabbis and telling me the reason we
don't eat pig is because God said right
and that's the end of it.
Well I think that they probably ate it
and probably try to eat it raw and
people got deathly ill and children died
now.
That's what I think,
you know,
whenever I'm like don't after enough
many generations that you don't,
it's like why?
It's like our God,
you know?
Here it is.
The Sun,
God says tide as a phenomenon caused by
algae blooms during which algae becomes
so numerous that it does color,
blah,
blah.
The release toxins that may cause
illnesses in humans or other animals.
Huh.
So this is for whatever it is that
Google,
red tide,
shellfish.
I'm just trying to figure out why you're
not,
is it red tide shellfish here?
I think they might be talking about a
slightly different thing.
Nope.
It's the same stuff.
So consumption of shellfish that are
contaminants by the toxins can Taz,
neurotoxic,
shellfish poisoning.
NSP symptoms usually appear when a
couple of hours of eating contaminated
shellfish and they last for a few days,
so that is red tide.
So most likely something like that.
I can say that the reason why they chose
to not eat shellfish and tricking gnosis
is really common.
And pigs,
because they eat everything.
They eat rats,
pigs eat everything they can.
They ground nesting birds.
The I could for sure.
See that's why.
That's why that started up and obviously
like the don't fucking nerve.
His wife that's so I move,
I'll be fighting.
Just Scott says don't do that.
Yeah.
God says,
stop fucking everybody.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's some of them that are real
universal's right.
They travel from every,
every religion.
It's like people figured out rules that
you should operate by to have a
harmonious existence with your
neighbors.
Yeah.
But then other ones,
it's just ridiculous.
Now that I'm stepped back and someone
will ask me about a of mock,
oh,
I just started laughing about what the
purpose was and how it looks from the
outside.
We've talked about the one that's in Old
Testament where God sends a bunch of
bears down to kill kids because they
were making fun of this guy being bald.
What?
Yes.
Really?
Some of these,
I don't even know.
That's a crazy thing.
This is one of the best ones ever.
This guy is,
he's,
these kids are taunting this guy and
calling him bald and so God sends these
bears.
This guy's doing God's work and God
protects his people.
God sends some fucking,
she bears to eat these kids,
dude,
pull it up so I can,
right.
Here it is.
Oh,
Alicia,
Alicia and the two bears make that a
little beer for my shitty sort of
profits.
Yeah.
This is the way it's described as
hilarious.
Whereas you're bald head.
This is what they're saying.
Go up you bald head to him.
Uh,
when he looked behind him and saw them,
he cursed them in the name of the Lord,
all caps.
Then two female came out of the woods,
tore up 42 lads up their number and he
went,
that is fucking insane.
You're supposed to read into that.
Here's the actual thing.
So like some shit was happening baby.
Maybe a different time,
maybe not like fun and then fucking
bears killed a bunch of these people
that happened.
Yeah.
For just had to read into why the for
sure definitely people got killed by
bears but lived inside a whale and they
didn't say miracle on that.
They just said the way later but didn't
fucking swallow and he was just there
like the Pelican.
What the fuck did,
I just was operating from it.
Not An understanding of how things work.
Yeah.
Like where they made star wars in
fucking,
what's the name of shooting that?
That rudder and it was just open to
space because we didn't know yet that
like,
oh,
that'll just kill you.
You can't just have open the space.
You need like a barrier there.
Yeah.
That would be like 250 degrees below
zero just like it's an open window is
firing out.
Yeah.
You can't do that.
But we didn't know any better.
It's like not sounds right or you can
live inside a whale.
Like if you're in space and someone
breaks the window shoot match if you're
in some s cause you know that number,
that alien,
that one alien movie,
the bullet hole he got dragged out.
That was pretty bad ass.
But what's his face?
Bayzos is going to offer flights to
space.
Do you know that?
Right?
Like I'm a 2019 that's a good question.
I saw him two days ago.
I would be willing to pay.
Would you be willing to pay 10 grand,
10 grand,
20 I think.
I think 20 grants.
The first number that came to mind was
50 but that's a lot.
A lot.
But for the experience I might think
would be good though.
Yeah.
It's can't just be get up and go back.
Now you're right.
What if it's fucking lame?
You got to take 10 10 number one flat
earth.
Conspiracist he should be the first one
to go for sure.
You got to tell everybody,
man,
you've gotta be willing to tell
everybody what you see.
Tell everybody it's a ball.
It's a ball.
There is no rocket.
It is all CGI.
Everything is artificial.
We live in,
it's been proven.
We live in a hologram.
Hey,
what questions you want to ask me about
anthony?
Bordain well,
I wanted to talk to you about suicidal
thoughts because you are out of the
people that didn't kill themselves with
you are a lot,
huh?
The one who knows the most about it and
you've experienced depression,
you know,
and when I wasn't close with Anthony
Bordain but I really liked him a lot
when I'm with you.
Yeah.
And when I hung out with him,
I really enjoyed it.
I did a show,
we did an episode of his show in Montana
and we went camping together and got
fucked up by a campfire.
Yeah,
it was great.
We had a great,
great old time.
It was really fun.
But I was stunned when that happened.
And,
uh,
I mean I don't,
I just wanted to know,
like,
when you were at your worst,
when you were having like really shitty
feelings,
like what could have been anything that
someone could have done that could have
helped you?
Oh yeah.
I think about this too.
I lost a friend,
a suicide and it was like,
yeah,
you want to stop because like what,
what,
what could you have done?
Right.
Yeah.
I mean sometimes just all fall on me
into a therapist that fuck,
I couldn't afford.
I mean,
I've told you this before,
I probably on here.
That was like a physical thing to do,
but just getting me to go to accept like
that,
maybe it'll work well,
I,
I knew when I was talking to you,
that is a hard thing for you to talk
about.
So if you're bringing it up,
it's a real,
real issue.
Yeah.
It's,
you're stoic.
Yeah.
You're,
you're not,
you don't complain about that.
People with my negative stuff,
he's done.
So I remember we were playing pool and I
was like,
what's matter?
Like there's something going on.
Like you just seem like just unhappy or,
and so once we got you into that
psychiatrist and dude,
you popped out of that thing like a
fucking spring pills.
Yeah.
Neat.
We went running,
like anybody who thinks that pills are
all bad,
I don't think anything's all anything.
I think I know the black and white
problem where there are people,
like I talked to Benji won,
it seems like there are over prescribing
pills.
I'm like,
they worked for me and he's like,
well,
I probably didn't.
And I'm like,
no,
no.
Just because you think they're over
prescribing it doesn't mean they should
never prescribed.
Right.
It's,
there's stuff that works and sometimes
it works enough for you to just change
your way of looking at the world and
change your reality and then you
eventually weaned yourself off of them,
which is really interesting.
Well,
it's a sprain of the brain muscle is
what's happened.
Um,
I don't,
it's not like a physical,
like pull like that.
Um,
but that's really what it is.
Just a sprain.
And so like until you get off it,
uh,
to get on a cast,
if some way it's going to be real hard
for it to heal.
You know,
this is like so far this metaphor works
that does work.
It works in the most effective cases
like yours of medication.
So these pills act as a cast and then at
some point you're healed and you don't
need them anymore.
But the problem is the only way to
really know is if you just get off it
and run on it and then you're like,
oh fuck,
I'm still hurt.
Yeah.
And during that get off and run on a
time is you're suicidal thoughts shoot
up if they were going to.
So when they do wean you off,
they're like you need to keep up with
me.
Like anything you get,
you need to call me immediately you can
to write back on like what was
interesting with you is you are weaning
off coincided with huge success in your
career.
Yeah,
I got off him,
I know where I got off on,
it was my second apartment in New York.
So this was three and a half years ago,
four years ago maybe around there.
This is not happening is already on
comedy central.
It's things are going,
things are going good.
Your tours,
kicking ass,
everything's great.
And then you released my first hour and
then my second hour.
Yeah.
And you were a legit success.
He'll blow up.
Was getting you were on billboards.
So beyond that I was,
uh,
I mean more importantly was I was a
working comic.
I was like,
oh,
I can make a real living at this now for
the first time.
So that was like the best part.
Yeah.
And that hadn't been going on very long,
right?
Well,
it was a hot,
it's a fucking,
people don't know.
People don't know.
It's a fucking crazy struggle.
The struggle from open Miker to
successful working comedian and
everybody's different,
everybody's got their own weirdness that
they have to overcome,
but it's a long ass bloody struggle.
That's true.
By the way.
That's why I hate this infighting and
comedy.
It's terrible.
And it's like you're doing this wrong,
your dog.
I said,
guys,
we're all up against the most monumental
odds.
So you write safety,
safe show jokes and this guy writes Dick
Jokes.
It's like whatever.
That's just like predispositions,
but like it's hard.
We're all in the same boat anyway.
Yeah,
I agree man.
And that dot.
It didn't,
it's very rarely been the case in the
history of comedy that everybody kind of
got along and just accepted the fact
that everybody does things differently
and not make,
not,
don't make a big deal out of it.
Yeah.
We'd have to have factions inside of
our,
it's one you want to have a safe space
show.
I get it.
Yeah.
It's,
people don't want to hear shit like
that.
It's okay.
Have you ever been a show?
Have Your Black Knight?
That's fine to have everything.
Everyone's defensive.
Oh my.
Everyone wants to hold their ground and
stand up for their position on things.
It's like,
okay,
you going to be fine.
Everyone's going to prison or just,
it's the best time ever.
Just kick ass.
Just keep writing.
Just go out there and do it.
Um,
yeah.
And then it got better.
But a lot of that was it.
The focus I was able to get because of
these,
it was rent.
Uh,
no,
not well beach.
I tried Wellbutrin.
The problem is some of these pills like
the side effects are not worth it.
So what I tell people,
like someone had a problem once,
a fucking anxiety,
um,
use of,
I don't care about this shit nicky was
and um,
and uh,
he's right now planning on bombing out
embassy and it was like he didn't want
to go on it cause he was afraid it would
make him like a Zombie.
And I'm like,
okay,
if it does,
just go back off it so you don't have to
commit forever.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Just see what the effects are.
So on I think Wellbutrin,
uh,
I couldn't come.
Oh it was fresh and I,
I wouldn't even say it was any sort of
psycho periodic
thing cause I didn't know about that as
a side effect until that was happening
with my girlfriend at the time.
And I was like,
what the fuck?
I was like three times in a row.
I was like,
it just couldn't come.
And then she was like,
oh,
maybe it's those pills.
I'm like,
why?
Really?
And then I looked,
I was like,
oh yeah,
fucking annoying.
It's an annoying thing.
That's super annoying.
There was this one called rem or Ron.
Think about like how many circuits there
are matching so much in there.
And I'll think of something that gets in
there and fixes this was like,
Hey,
I'm going to take that away.
They come thing,
oh it's like you edit your own computer.
My God.
Like by taking those,
it's almost like you edit your own
opera.
Remember when you have a a pc you can
get into dos defragging,
do shit.
Yeah.
That's almost like what you're doing.
So the side effect on run run,
these side effects don't hit everybody
the same and what you're looking to fill
in isn't all the same.
So don't just get with somebody else
gets you got to talk to a therapist.
But like Rem Ron gave me hyper Phasia
oh.
Which is the inability to be feel full.
So they said expect to gain 15% of your
body weight.
And I could eat,
dude,
if I got high,
I could eat like eight plates of
Spaghetti.
I mean,
I would eat out my whole apartment.
Holy Shit.
Everything.
It got to the point where I was like,
well,
I got one big left,
some peanut butter and some a little bit
of Cheerio's and fucking let's do this.
It was,
and it was glorious,
but that it wasn't helping me.
That was a problem.
That was a side effect because I was
thin then I could have dealt with,
I can be 15 pounds overweight instead of
10 pounds underweight,
but like,
it didn't help me mentally.
Mm.
Um,
and then I finally got on one to
separate me.
That was like,
it worked.
I was like,
boom,
I'm out.
I get it.
I'm free now a little bit.
Um,
but low blood pressure.
So sometimes I stayed up,
I got to hold on to something and like,
it's not fucking faint,
but barely ever happens.
Totally worth it.
And that still happens now when I get
high.
But like,
do you get like,
dizzy lightheaded?
Yeah,
I stand up.
I'm like,
hold on,
you got to get real high with for that
to happen or early or something like
that.
Or if I'm getting sick,
that'll happen.
But I used to get that in high school
too.
I think I'm already predisposed to it,
but they made it a little worse.
Not,
not a big deal though.
So I finally found the one that worked
for me,
but it's hard and if you're not having
it,
your brain is lying to you or it's
giving you a version of reality that's
like,
I mean I saw this last night coming home
from the airport from Burbank airport
and some lady picked up in an Uber,
picked up a guy on the wrong side of the
fence and she was,
sorry it's my first time here.
But like it's one of those little fences
you can just step over almost,
you know?
And he's like,
well everyone else is gone here.
And she's like,
yeah,
sorry.
It's my first time at the Burbank
airport I can and you can't get to walk
10 seconds to where it's an opening and
he's white.
It's like pop the trunk,
pop the trunk place,
and I'm like,
Oh,
you're cranky from flying.
I know what that is.
And so your version of this reality is
this is a way worse thing than it really
is.
Steve Simone who never gets upset,
which was like,
I know deal,
I'll just come around and then it's
over.
It's the same thing we've talked to
Fitzsimmons like you can just not punch
somebody and then forget about it.
But you know,
if you're,
if you're thinking that angrily all the
time,
it's really affects you and this shit
makes you think the worst of everything.
Wow.
It's like,
yeah,
no matter what it is so little worse
than it should be an interesting way of
looking at it.
Yeah.
And it just gets tiring after awhile and
the suicidal thoughts start happening
when you're like,
I can't do this anymore.
You know,
it's effort.
It's mental effort to just like,
oh,
it just keeps,
it's like you've got to rock on you that
you're pulling up,
pushing off you at all times and you
just need the game to be over.
You just need a sleep.
Theo is to have a bit about,
I think he probably didn't have special
or something by now,
but it was like if you want that deep
sleep,
deep sleep,
like that's what it is,
where you just want to sleep forever.
You just weighed down by it all the
time.
Yeah.
It's like,
you know how they used to like,
um,
get people to give false confessions by
just keeping them awake for like 30
straight hours until they eventually,
like they don't know how to say no.
The fine I did it and stuff they did
didn't do,
they weren't anywhere near it,
but they're just saying,
yes,
I murdered somebody,
let me sleep.
It's just a version of that,
you know,
where you're just like,
he's just so sick of it.
After a while I will tell you that they
have read about it and they say the
people who talk about suicide or sort of
different,
the people who are thinking about it
quietly,
who quietly is weight way more often to
commit it.
Um,
I think they say the people talking
about it as a way to seek help.
So what can you do it,
the question was what could you do to
help people?
Is there anything that anybody could
have done?
You know,
it used to make me mad when you told me
just get out of bed to some exercise.
I was like,
you don't get it.
You don't get it.
I definitely don't get it.
Yeah.
Shandra understood at once.
She was like talking about that.
She was like,
he doesn't understand.
You can't even go to your fridge.
Like exercise is not even just so far
from like no way I could couldn't even
get out of bed.
What do you think was,
you were also taking propecia then it
had anything to do with it because
that's one of the site event I'm for
sure.
Might have.
I mean it was right around then and I
think,
I'm trying to think,
um,
if I was quitting right then on it and
switched into the fucking spread,
um,
come on.
Stem cell research.
But I think it was either on it or,
or,
or getting off it.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
Could have had something to do with
that.
Yeah,
I think so too.
It was also,
um,
uh,
live in girl.
I mean,
there was so many things right around
that.
So all it takes is a sprain.
So like here's a weird thing.
Let's say you lost your job and that
sends you into a depression.
It's not,
that is not related to something.
A lot of times it will be related,
something a mom dies,
dad dies.
But let's say the job situation,
because you can change this,
right?
Your Dad dies,
you'll never get them back.
You know,
it feels bad.
And so like it should bad,
you lose your job,
you go into depression,
but now you get a better job.
You know what I mean?
Not that you will,
but let's just say you did the
depression remains.
The causes of depression is necessarily
gone.
You're doing better than the thing that
made you depressed,
but you're still depressed because that
brain is sprained.
Oh,
so you need a way to fight it.
And pills don't work for everybody.
So it's fucking disheartening.
And getting the right,
I had a therapist say,
well,
I was like this,
this one,
pills not working.
It's like,
wow,
I don't know what to tell Ya.
And I was like,
and in my head I was just like,
okay,
I accept it all.
Work up the courage eventually,
and that'll be the end of it.
I was like,
well,
am I going to fight you on it?
I don't want to fight this in the first
place.
It's not going to work.
How she was the worst,
what was it like to get pulled out of
the clouds?
Like when the pills,
the pills started working,
working at first it's like you don't
trust that it's gone.
It's like right when the hiccups leave,
you still feel like you're the hiccups,
right?
You know,
but like a way longer version of that.
And then what happens weird is you start
to miss it because it became so much of
your reality and who you were that like
it's this thing that's been pulled away
from you.
A part of you is gone.
Hmm.
So it's weird that you're like,
miss this horrible way of being,
um,
because you had to figure out a way to
like make a positive at this.
And you see this a lot in like pc
culture,
we start sort of bragging about your
victimization that things have happened
to you,
but like it's a way to stand out and be
a special so that you ended up propping
the,
the negative up instead of,
instead of saying,
yeah,
that was shitty.
You know,
you started almost like bragging about
it,
right?
So you start feeling like,
well at least I'm different.
So that can prop you up a little.
At least I'm unique in this thing of
like it doesn't seem like anyone else's
having these suicidal thoughts,
you know?
Um,
it's almost like if you're only the only
one to do a band,
you feel better than if everyone else
into that same band.
The band is,
the album is the album.
But you'd like it more because you're
the only one,
right?
The oldest in your own uniqueness.
It's like maybe it was that,
I'm not really sure,
but when I was out of it,
that was missing it a little bit and
then followed by a fear that it's going
to come back because regular,
okay.
That's a terrible word.
Depression because it also means just,
I'm depressed today.
Clinical depression is different but
overlaps,
you know,
it doesn't just go away if I'm depressed
because I'm cranky,
I got to tell myself,
don't be cranky.
Say Five things.
You're thankful for you.
She'll be out of it.
Get some sunshine,
you're fine.
This is like deeper.
So like then when you do get depressed,
like let's just say I haven't been
outside all day.
It's been raining for two straight days,
you know,
he just a little like blue.
You're like,
oh fuck,
is it back?
You know?
And then when it's gone in a day like Oh
God,
but when it's like two days like fuck
fuck,
don't come back.
Wow.
Yeah.
But the the so about like a bad weather
day could set it off a little bit.
No,
that just gives like the normal
depression that everybody gets right at.
That's,
I think there really should be two
separate terms.
Feeling Blue Fail and blue you get it
hadn't been on stage in four days.
I feel a little blue if I,
if I,
I didn't know if I can get my underwear
out all day too.
I can't live in Vancouver.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Those people get depressed.
It don't go outside in Seattle.
They don't get outside while they get
outside where they get rained on.
Yeah.
So it's just like he just feeling down.
I remember when Duncan and I were
filming something up there and we were
doing that big foot foot and we were
talking to this guy who was a cop who
was like the security guard for the set
and he was like,
dude,
it fucking wears on you.
He was,
he was at the end of like the rainy
season.
It was just starting to get warm again.
The New York,
my first New York went to was this one
and it wasn't so much middle of March
where I was like,
whatever I could,
I could take it.
I took the winter,
it was middle of April where I'm like
[inaudible] already I put in the three
or four months.
Oh,
so the question is the want though.
What the thing is,
you could do what you want.
You could leave.
I could leave.
I went skiing a lot of 16 days of skiing
this year.
When did that around like road dates.
That's what's crazy about like somewhere
like denver,
like it's sunny,
sunny.
It's great.
So much better.
When it's sunny,
it's cold out,
but it's still,
it's sunny.
Like if you have to pick warm and cloudy
all the time or cold and sunny.
I take cold and sunny all day long.
Yeah,
for sure.
All Day long.
Sunny.
Sunny?
Yeah.
Skiing outside of the sun when it's
like,
Oh,
it's 25 degrees,
but it's just,
you don't even walking around.
Yeah,
it's brisk out,
but look how pretty the sky is blue,
blue sky and fluffy clouds.
Did you know Anthony Bordain was was
depressed?
No.
I heard with him a little.
It was a mixture of mixing drugs,
mixing pills and alcohol could have the
hammer.
I bow,
I believe he was on some sort of malaria
medication,
which is dangerous if some people
violent people get violent.
I've seen people on malaria medication
while they were drinking.
And I had a hold the guy back from
attacking or the quarter or at least
worried about him attacking a report.
It was a friend of mine.
It was a very kind friend of mine who I
will,
I don't think we'd ever in normal life
attack a person physically.
And it seemed like he was about to text.
It makes you think not even normal.
He was squirrely.
Um,
it was,
he had to go to Africa for,
he had,
uh,
he had um,
visit somewhere in Africa and he had to
take these pills and some of them have
violent reactions to people.
You're not supposed to drink on them,
first of all.
And he was drinking.
It's mixing.
Yeah.
And you know,
if that's what he was doing and he's
mixing that with alcohol,
who fucking knows.
So that could have happened with board
and where,
it might not have been long term
depression,
but I know there's studies on people who
got a concussion in football practice
and then hung themselves at night.
Oh yeah.
No history of it.
But right then everything,
I mean it's almost like you're on
psychedelics.
This new reality is real.
It feels real.
So the question is,
is there something you could've done?
I don't know.
I don't know what the right,
I've thought about it.
I don't know what the right thing is.
Cause you,
you push away people's help.
Right?
I saw somebody posted on facebook once
where it was like one of the worst
things about depression is everybody
going to key.
I've been through that too.
It's like now I'm not even unique,
you know,
getting by props for my individual
substance.
So then it's like you want to help by
somebody saying you,
I've been through this,
but it's like,
it's not even helping them,
but like who the fuck knows what they're
feeling?
Right.
That's the other thing about a person's
feelings,
what they're feeling.
It's very personal.
It's almost impossible to describe.
Oh,
by the way,
I had moderate depression.
That's where the therapist said what you
saw was moderate depression.
Jesus,
I don't know what severe depression
looks like.
Jesus.
So I don't know,
man.
I don't know.
I lost somebody to,
and I don't know if I could have said
something to her or like,
you know,
um,
anthony like to drink.
He drank a lot.
Yeah.
And uh,
watching him over the last four years,
like you could see that he's,
he'd seemed like he had been living a
hard life.
You know,
he looked like it on television too.
You've been living a hard life.
I mean,
he was out there hitting it,
traveling from country to country,
constantly drinking constantly.
Alcohol's a depressant.
I mean it just is,
if you drink alcohol all the time,
you're not going to come out of it with
a sunny disposition as the president.
It is a depressant.
I mean,
you can definitely do it and pull it
off.
And we do.
And you know,
occasionally you'll have a couple of
drinks and then the next day you won't.
But if you're doing that all the time,
if you doing it every day,
five days a week,
a lot of people use that because it's a
short term relief from depression,
longterm depressant.
So a lot of people use alcoholism to
cover up the depression and then they
get clean.
Suddenly all the shit they're supposed
to have been dealing with is now still
there and not being covered up by
alcohol.
Yeah.
Fun that comes with a couple of drinks.
The,
there's a fuck.
Absolutely.
It's fun.
Fuck it.
Let's stop worrying.
Yeah.
It spends how addicted to,
I can't,
I wish I could do that with cigarettes
when everybody's smoking,
but I'll go right back to a pack.
So do you do,
do you,
do you think like fuck,
what could I have done?
No,
cause I wasn't close enough to them and
I wasn't there.
If I was there,
I would be tortured by it.
Yeah.
If I was there and I was hanging out
with them and it happened in [inaudible]
you tomorrow and then I would have been
tortured by that,
that would then with anybody,
you know,
it's just such a crazy decision to make
the decision to just stop living when so
many people loved you and you have this
crazy life that,
uh,
it's the bravest thing to me.
Yeah.
I can't imagine it's,
it's,
that's the only thing that held me back
is just the lack of courage to be like,
just do it.
And it's like,
let it stop.
Your DNA is telling you,
but stop and think about you.
What you've from not doing that you
become wildly successful.
Yeah.
And way happier.
You're having a great fucking time at a
great time.
It,
I have the architect of my own happiness
and his fucking,
I'm doing it well while I'm doing myself
doing it the way you're supposed to do
it,
but you're,
you know,
you've been doing it like this for
several years now and if you,
I guess it really doesn't matter in the
end,
but if you end your own life,
you didn't ever experienced all this
true.
But if you had to go back and do it
again,
it's interesting.
You were at like a tipping point,
Matt,
you're this like weird tipping point and
you just went that way and you're free.
Just took a while.
It was definitely a struggle.
But you,
you were free I find when talking to
comics,
other comics because now I feel a little
guilty,
you know,
for success around around people that
are also quite funny who don't have it.
And what I found is that it's,
you get this frustrating point right
around eight,
nine,
10 12 years of comedy where like your
skills have gotten better and your
monetary career has not gotten better.
Seo,
artistic careers booming and then you're
just not even making a living.
And it's the most frustrating cause like
I'm finally good at open mic level.
Like,
or make a good joke that's a window and
so on.
I made a good joke tonight,
this week or one time this month,
you know,
but like they are,
it's like I'm doing so well on stage,
I'm killing,
why am I,
why am I still working this day job?
Why am I not even ever on TV?
Why am I,
you know?
And it's real frustrating.
Might've been around that time too or
just getting frustrated with like,
you know,
I was less hacky but also just not
succeeding.
I say an interesting how the Internet's
changed everything or for,
you can support people so much easier.
Before it was like you had the man show
you could hire a writer and that's it.
That's the only help you could do for
someone.
Yeah.
You know,
take a couple people on the road with
you,
but now it's like,
Hey,
go watch this guy show,
hey,
this guy's got under special.
Hey,
check out so and so's got a new book,
you know,
changes everything.
Yeah.
And people are going and it's literally
no skin off your back.
Yeah.
It's like whatever.
Well,
it's great actually.
It's good.
Like I,
if Tom Papa asked me to promote
something he's doing,
I want people to go see him.
It's good.
It's good for me.
I want them to do good because I like
listening to him.
I like watching them,
so I want them to make more comedy.
Oh yeah.
Then you went,
because I get to see you more.
I got to get to sell out.
Comedy person gets to stay in it.
Not that he needs us,
but it also will,
like with Tom,
when you tell people about someone who's
really funny,
whether it's you or whoever it is,
then they trust you.
They'll go,
I want to see that guy.
He's a fucking Lexia.
They know that you're telling the truth.
Like if I tell him,
Hey Joey Diaz,
the funniest guy that's ever lived and
you go see him at the Ice House one
night and come out of it and you,
you're bleeding,
your,
your internal bruising for laughing.
I love guaranteeing people on twitter or
whatever.
It's like,
you don't know.
I guarantee you will have a great night.
This is someone who has an awesome
comic.
Just,
just,
there's no like,
well my friend,
it's like just,
they'll be great.
There's,
there's people that you could do that
with.
But yeah,
there was no,
you know,
before it was like you got on the
tonight show,
you know,
he did say that was an actual times that
a letterman people talked about.
You had to build up places,
you had to travel to places all the
time.
So those people would come back every
time they came back.
You better have some new shit to it.
I really got to think about it.
I have like when you start saying that
depression of people,
like what can you do?
Anybody do?
Is there anything anybody can do?
It's like just a little bit like being
there for you sometimes is like helpful.
Just be like,
hey man,
you're just your good friend.
I know you're going through something,
but just know that I like you just like
a little bit and don't require anything
of them.
But I guess everybody be different too.
But like,
I don't know,
don't know.
Everybody's on a different trip.
That's the thing.
It's like no one knows what anyone is
feeling.
Telling somebody to get over it is not
the way to do it.
That's,
that ain't gonna help.
The tough love thing is like that.
It doesn't work.
That works for fucking nothing.
I don't know what it works for,
but not that it works for lazy people.
Yeah.
I don't think it works for them.
I don't even think it works for them.
I think that gets people to move
sometimes,
but it doesn't change the way they think
about what they're doing.
They just get forced into doing,
you know,
it's like the argument,
well actually not like that when I was
going to say,
but it's,
it's you.
You want them to act and so they act
because of force of your your will.
You're trying to scare them into it.
Yeah,
but if you inspire someone and say to
him,
listen,
I know you're looking at it this way.
This is why this is going to hurt you by
approaching it this way.
You're going to do the same thing.
But instead of approaching it the way
you're approaching it,
stop.
And just for a shifted perspective,
think about it in a positive way.
Like you could do that to people and
sometimes you can actually shift the way
they look at something because a lot of
times it's the way you're approaching
something that's pissing you off about
it.
And the way to get through sometimes to
people is not to tell them this is the
way you should do it.
But just to paint the picture and let
them make their own decision.
Yeah.
To be like,
Oh sir,
you're happy when you're run.
Yeah.
Okay.
Is it,
is it warm out?
Oh,
it is.
Okay.
I don't know.
You're less happening.
You don't run.
All right.
Well was like,
instead of be like,
you got to get out there and run.
I,
you know,
I have kids raising kids.
One of the things that I learned that
works really good is anytime they do
anything,
I tell them I fucked up way worse than
you.
I don't use word fucked.
All right?
And I said,
whatever you've done,
I've messed up way more like I,
everybody messes up.
Don't worry about it.
This is a part of being a kid and I'm
super proud of you for admitting that
you made a mistake or that you did this.
This is great because this is how you
learn.
You're not supposed to know everything.
You're eight years old or you're 10
years old.
You're supposed to be learning,
learning about life and people who are
supposed to be talking to you about
various things you encounter.
You don't supposed to already know
everything.
You're a little kid.
This is great.
So we learned something that we don't
want to do anymore.
This is great.
This is an awesome opportunity.
And nobody,
I wish somebody talked to me like that
and I will tell them that too.
I go cause I get called stupid and
yelled at or whatever.
Whatever the fuck it was when I did
something.
This is how people talk to kids back
then they didn't,
you know,
it's not
even anybody's fault.
So does something dumb.
You know,
in the 1960s or something like that.
They threw things at them.
You know,
like my,
my parents were telling me about things
flying across the room at them.
You know,
like people might stop,
they just fucking that little,
the kids were animals back then too.
You know,
people are different.
Yeah.
So I might be that like something that
helped me,
I don't know if people are listening are
going through it or whatever,
but like some things that will help that
I was able to take was I had one
therapist said one good thing where it's
like imagine the good things out of the
depression.
Yeah.
Instead of looking at it as only
negative,
um,
what's it helped you with?
And then I was like,
well I'm,
it'll try that.
And I was like,
I'm looking at my standup material more
realistically and darker and that's
actually helpful on stage.
He was like,
all right,
cool.
That's one good thing out of this.
And then it just like sort of,
it might just help you like it's not all
bad.
Adjust the way you approach it.
Yeah.
Another thing was say five things and
just in the shower,
whenever you do shower,
say five things out loud that you're
thankful for doesn't have to be
monumental stuff.
Just like it's 75 today.
That's good.
Um,
I got a new bar soap.
That's cool.
Um,
uh,
my friend John,
you know,
whatever,
Brian,
I like him.
That's cool.
Glad to have that in my life.
Just five things to say it out loud and
then after a while sometimes that that
that ended up like affecting my mood,
you know,
where instead of,
cause that was the problem was the
focus.
I don't know if I ever told you this
focus on negative things.
Yeah,
so it'd be like a 75 degree day.
This is the example I use 75 degrees and
sunny.
It's fucking every day in La,
you know?
And I would be like,
instead of going like this is fucking
Rad,
it's February 12th and I am fucking in
shorts,
this is great.
Instead of focusing in that,
I would focus on like fuck,
I got,
I got my car has no gas,
I got to fucking go kick gas.
I hate having to fucking get gas.
You got to pull over.
And so then I'm only focusing on this
fucking one minute chore,
but I have to do instead of on all the
good stuff.
And so you just focus,
it just makes you focus on this negative
and he's just like can't pull out of it.
So anything you can do to like shift the
focus to the positive is helpful.
Do you know Tony Vee is standup comics
and bosses?
I'm a part of them.
Very,
very funny guy.
Said something to me once about,
he was driving from New York to Boston
back and forth like multiple times in a
week.
I go,
dude,
that's long.
That's a long ass drive.
And he goes,
yeah,
but I just go zen and I just tell
myself,
this is what I'm doing right now.
Right.
I just do it.
Yeah.
But I thought about that and I go,
yeah,
why don't you just do that?
Just say this is what I'm doing right
now instead of like going fuck,
can't believe to drive this thing.
Yeah.
So fucking long.
What if I fall asleep?
How do you make yourself think about it
positively.
Fucking hard.
Somebody,
when I told all my norm,
norm core people about like start doing
commercials and then they're like,
how does it work?
And I'm like,
can you give an agent given 10% like,
well,
he doesn't go to the auditions,
don't you hate giving a 10% you know,
and you probably this too from people.
And you're like,
no,
I mean,
I remember thinking like that.
It's like I wouldn't get the auditions
without them.
That is nothing compared to what he
does.
You want a bunch of people,
there's people don't understand.
So it's like don't focus on that
negative shit.
Focusing on the 90% like I wasn't even a
thing like 20 feet sounds like.
What's not even thinking like,
oh this is such a sucky thing.
Well he just had a great way of
approaching it.
Yeah,
this is what I'm doing right now.
So this is what I'm doing.
If you can emulate those people,
it's hard to move.
It's hard.
Light them.
Then it's like help you move the needle
a little bit.
You know?
So maybe that one day you're like,
fuck it,
this is the,
the boulders too hard today.
Maybe if you got like one nicer thing
and you're like,
ah,
I can withstand it.
And that was the day you were going to
commit suicide.
Maybe it'll just like last you through.
This is a culture of,
uh,
attacking and trying to destroy people
today that didn't exist before and that
can affect your mood.
Yeah.
I think we're seeing that with,
uh,
people in the news and when people do,
like,
the thing about that lady,
and I'm the little kid,
the little eight year old,
she's calling the cops on him.
The thing that bummed me out the most is
that they didn't accept her apology.
Yeah.
It's like,
c'mon,
c'mon.
That's the thing that brought me,
I'll send,
I'll start.
What she did was gross for sure,
but we want people to just suffer
forever.
Like the pain that lady must've felt
from all those thousands of emails and
hate tweets she got from ratting out
that little kid that,
no,
you don't have to pile on it.
She got it.
And does is good for everybody.
That's good for everybody.
But you know what else is good for
everybody,
right?
Forgiveness,
forgiveness as good if someone asks.
Yeah.
Just you say we forgive you.
It's,
I can't get for owning up to it.
I appreciate it.
You know,
you were wrong.
They fucked up and she probably didn't
know she fucked up.
She probably was hormonal and she's
probably not,
you know,
not thinking so good.
And the whole thing to be like,
all right.
You said,
you said you're sorry.
It's all bad.
She,
she did never done that.
And who knows if she would have done it?
Everybody kid.
She said it to the people.
Hey,
one on one.
I'm sorry.
I did.
That was,
that was my bad.
Yeah.
You people,
you kind of got to let people learn and
grow.
You know,
I don't accept your apology.
Oh,
so it's like nothing happened to the
daughter,
right.
She didn't get arrested is a creepy
experience fill.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean it really is.
Imagine some,
fuck you and accept your apology.
Fucking pro wrestling size white lady.
Remember that old lady after the,
after the court trial and she punched
out of the lady in the face.
Oh yeah.
That was a good one.
She was like,
yeah,
your daughter does.
And she's like,
fuck y'all face and rub it in right now.
Say you're sorry.
Yeah.
Be a be a positive winter.
Except an apology of the loser.
Yeah,
man.
It's just people aren't here for that.
Long as a Rhonda Rousey was garbage too
and that lady was like,
Hey,
I'm sorry.
Good fight.
She's like,
fuck off.
Get Out to talk about my family.
It's like you're white trash.
Well she's a super winner.
Those super winners is taking it down a
notch.
I had heard if you lose a game or if
Michael Jordan lose a game of pool,
he wouldn't talk to you for like two
weeks.
Really?
It's crazy.
If you heard that you've heard shit like
that.
Right.
I heard that he wears crazy giant pants
just in case someone ever wants to play
one on one.
He could pull those fucking pants off.
He'd go,
yeah.
Cause he used to rumor,
he was the bet with the rest of the
team.
What he wears giant ass pants.
Those are pull away.
He's ready to fuck you.
So competitive Houston bet with the rest
of the team who's bag was going to come
out first.
What?
Like a hundred bucks or 1000 bucks and
then pay the fucking later pay the
people at the airport like,
Hey,
when my back comes,
you need to let it come off first.
I want to win that fucking bed.
Oh Geez.
Yeah.
That's fucked up.
He rigged the system.
Yeah,
he was a degenerate gambler or still is
with the hundreds of millions of
dollars,
which is a crazy combination with the
killed his father.
That was the rumor.
Right?
A lot of people say that.
That's so scary.
If that was true,
that he didn't steal anything from them,
they just killed him.
That is so scary.
And people like,
why don't they killed Jordan then?
Cause I'm,
they don't get their money.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Did they ever catch the guy who killed
his dad?
I don't believe they did.
They did.
Do you think they did the same jail?
Somebody was contacting me about this
one guy from jail.
Now they spoken to him in jail about
this.
She was a mafia hit man.
Or you think it was a dude?
Have you watched wild,
wild country?
It's the best.
Holy Shit.
Okay.
When you're one or two episodes into
that,
I'm four episodes in.
Perfect.
So you can get this.
Um,
how much of you thinks,
oh,
Duncan could start one of these a
thousand,
a thousand peace and happiness and
fucking wearing the same shit.
It's a great dude.
I was talking to these people seem cool.
I was talking to my friend todd and he
was like,
dude,
I,
I wanted to live like that.
Two episodes in,
and they're like,
yeah man,
what the fuck?
I'll wear red.
It was like the first episodes of sons
of anarchy opposite way it looks and
they seem like they're happy.
They are happy.
They're having a good old time.
The duplass brothers made that those
guys are bad ass.
Yeah.
That's an amazing documentary.
It's fuck it.
Right?
This story is so insane.
While I'm watching,
I'm like,
how the fuck did I not know,
not know about it?
It was so good that I thought it was a
work for a while.
I would say.
I think they might be faking this.
Oh God.
So obviously Tom Brokaw talking about
it,
you're like,
all right.
I guess.
I guess it's never happened.
I got a friend of mine,
his girlfriend's parents were in that
group.
Really?
Yeah,
and they still,
they still follow that guy's teachings.
They still believe in him.
The mog.
Why the o show?
Is that his name?
His name?
What was his name?
It wasn't Mogra.
That's gremlins.
A picture that I had of him that I put
up on my instagram page of him holding
this white guy's head,
and this guy's like coming in his pants.
He was one of the freakiest this up
Jamie.
He's just playing like,
you can have money.
You can have nice things.
Yeah.
22 fucking Rolls Royce.
Let's look at this.
Oh,
he'll get the guy.
The guy's like,
oh my,
why are you touching you?
I'm so white.
He's touching both of them at the same
time.
Lefthand and the dude right hand the
girl,
he's like transmitting through them,
giving them orgasms.
Look at him.
He's like,
oh,
oh my God.
They believed in it,
man.
I get it.
We're all going to fucking go ahead.
Go ahead and pitch the crazy.
Have you seen any of this Jamie?
I think I turned it on and fell asleep
and having to tell you.
You believe that shit,
dude.
It's fucking amazing,
man.
I'm,
I'm on episode four now and I don't want
to give anything away,
uh,
in,
in terms of like how it goes down,
but it literally keeps ramping up and
getting more and more fucking insane.
I,
I've,
I'm like what Ari said,
I can't believe I didn't hear about
this.
How do we know about Jones town?
Everybody knows don't drink the Koolaid.
This is an Oregon outside of antelope,
Oregon too.
I mean,
I don't want to,
I can't give too much away,
but these people bought a town,
they bought the whole town.
They got a police force.
Do they have their own police force?
What are the odds that something like
that is going on now?
It's super low.
It's super low because what this is is
they,
what the government had stepped in and
realize that there's some shenanigans
going on and they were essentially,
there was no separation of church and
state because the church was the state,
right?
They had a government and police force
that was run by the church.
They called it a peace force and the
whole cult basically ran the town except
for a few diehards who didn't want to
give their houses up.
So there was some folks who had been
living in antelope their whole life.
They didn't give their houses up and
they're telling the story and they did
not care for it.
It was fucking amazing,
man.
So jealous of you of having not seen the
whole next call.
And this is another one,
right?
It's a different one.
It's the one with the actress that got
calories.
So that's,
is that a similar type cult things that
deal with that actress?
I don't know.
She did.
She really recruit people knowing it was
a sex cult.
I don't know if that's the same thing.
I don't have as many people.
I don't know much about this sex cult
thing with that actress lady.
I was like,
the whole story starts branding.
They were branding people but she was,
she was a part of it and she was
recruiting people into allegedly this is
what they're charging or what I feel is
more to the story than I did.
I can tell,
I don't know man,
but it's weird that people are so
susceptible to cults and that we protect
people from cults but don't protect
people from religions.
It's the same shit.
The only difference is this one guy is
banging all these people and we got to
stop that.
There was sex crimes,
there was like teen trafficking and
there was,
there was illegal things that were done
in this particular one,
from what I've read,
I don't know too much about it,
but then when you go to that Osho guy
and it seemed,
except for church and state.
See the thing is the church started
running the police force remember and
they had these guys walking around with
fucking,
you know,
semi automatic rifles and the high
powered machine guns and shit.
It was very different.
It was like,
okay,
you've
got a military force that's guarding
this religious leader.
Yeah.
So they had these police people at the
compound in the hallways with machine
guns.
These guys are playing assassin and
maybe they are the police force or not.
Then a private.
Exactly.
Uh,
what's it called?
Group.
I don't want to give any more away.
I just want to watch my watch and by the
way,
everything I've said is not going to
take anything away from sure.
With the girlfriend or your boyfriend or
your wife or whatever tool you're
neighbors with.
Somebody together.
Let's just like find somebody to be
like,
let's watch it one episode every two
days.
Let's talk about it.
Oh it's so fun.
I think an independent version of that
is in little blips.
What goes on with burning man,
like just independent little blip of
escape of norms of regular society.
And these people get there and they were
fucking gas masks and fuck each other
and go crazy and do cartwheels in the
dirt and they hang out together having a
great time and they realized that people
in at least in small bursts can
establish these communities,
set up all this temporary art,
have a great time.
And everybody's like,
you know,
really like likeminded,
know a lot of ways hanging out in this
one place.
Well,
if that's,
if people want that,
the only difference between that and
like a fulltime community is that you
would have to figure out a way to get
everybody to get along forever.
Well,
could just be a few days.
You'd have to have raised kids together,
get your food together,
do it,
but the food have all other jobs.
You have keyboards is a similar to that.
Yeah.
But if you tried to do that today,
they would stop you.
Or at least it would become a real
issue.
Like,
say if you decided you and Donkin got
together and you two decided to buy 700
acres in Oregon and you found some place
that you could all afford.
You did a kickstarter and you guys set
up a community out there.
You grew your own food,
you had your own,
well,
nobody can be married and you could fuck
anybody you want.
It's just how we live in.
That's how we live in.
And then you just,
you just rent and you like real loosely
based rules.
Hey,
when you eat something,
clean up your mess,
giant mess halls filled with people.
People have these houses all over this
fucking ranch and you,
you basically established a village.
Wow.
You get,
you just can't go too far.
Yeah.
But then we started getting money from
them.
Then the subway and when somebody breaks
the real law,
like there's a rape or murder,
you'd have to be like,
man,
we need to call them.
Yeah.
You have to call the cops.
The only way to keep it on file.
Yeah.
You'd have to keep it legit.
Like you'd have to still be under the
jurisdiction.
You'd have to make friends with the
local sheriffs.
That's you'd have to do just like we're
not,
we don't mean any harm,
but when we,
when we need you,
when something happens,
we'll call you.
But otherwise we're not going to need
your much.
Yeah,
we just got peer banging each other.
Paula,
I think each other like crazy skit
getting fucking wild up here,
son.
That's what we do.
It's legal,
right?
It's still leave it a fucking America.
If I pay taxes,
so my,
my,
my best buddies,
wife can suck my balls.
Ass fucking him.
Yeah.
That's what they're like.
Okay,
cool.
She likes to suck ball right next to the
boot heel.
I think a,
you would run into problems.
People would decide that you shouldn't
be living like that.
I don't want angry with everything
based.
It's with everything.
You're not living the way I live,
so I'm not going to let anyone be into
your shit.
Yeah.
But it's always like one dude,
right.
That's running things and I'm one of
those compounds.
Faults.
There's always like a main guy who
fucks.
Everybody fucks everybody's wife.
He's like,
fuck everybody you want.
But you probably want to fuck me.
It caught on the main dude.
The only way to do it,
honestly to do at burning man style.
This is my point is that burning man
style would be no leader.
No leader.
Yeah,
no leader.
So likeminded people,
And you'd have to fake,
the problem is charismatic people could
co op that they'd have these meetings.
One person takes over.
Look what we need here.
Some organization,
next thing you know he's the king.
You know,
that's how people do.
We're monkeys.
Yeah.
If we could avoid that though.
You crave leadership.
Yeah.
We'd have to somehow or another find a
way to not manipulate the way.
What's his,
as a seat laws,
are they,
yeah,
they're not the sex cult,
but they are like,
everyone has a job we're all working
for,
nobody makes money here.
Everybody makes 20 bucks a week.
Whatever it is,
you know,
room and board is paid for and that
makes people feel really good.
Yeah.
You're doing an equal part.
One guy could be running the accounting
for the thing.
One guy could be,
you know,
taking eggs.
You know,
one person takes care of the nursery of
the kids,
but like everyone joins in.
Do you ever see that a Werner Herzog
movie?
Um,
life in the taiga.
It's called a,
I think it's either called happiness.
Happiness are happy.
Happiness was a todd solondz movie that
was so good.
That was [inaudible].
We're like the best.
It was crazy.
Yeah,
it was crazy.
I think it's just called happy life in
the taiga and it's about these people
that live in Siberia.
They were like trappers and shit.
People Happy People.
They're the like the happiest people on
Earth.
They're all like having a great time
laughing.
And this is just how they live all the
time.
And all they do is go fishing and
hunting and trapping,
but they all get together and drink and
they,
in these villages,
they have fucking dog sleds that are
pulling them down the road and they're
driving around on jet skis and this is
how they live.
Like they live in the fucking Tundra.
Dude,
it's madness out there.
They raised these dogs.
They were the,
there were the happiest in that show.
Exactly right.
There was,
there's a lesson in there and I went to
that cave where it grit fucked Jon snow
did,
you can't swim in it anymore because it
was a fisher broke,
just was too hot.
I thought about jacking off and there
was people around town.
It'd be a thing to do,
you know,
if you want to get arrested for
something,
that's the thing to do.
You like,
Hey,
I'm a fan,
a fan.
I'm a fan.
I'm a real fan.
I've read the books and know where I'm
supposed to come.
We just get Osho to touch your head.
Hey,
you know what I was thinking what was in
the bathroom?
No,
what does that gave us some waterfall.
It's just him.
He's just showing US pretty images.
Facelift.
Jamie's Jamie's high as fuck over there
to shut up.
Um,
we
get to say,
how did you guys feel when I was going
through all of that?
Like what was the effect on you guys?
I was very nervous.
Yeah.
I was very nervous about you.
Um,
uh,
cause I don't,
um,
I didn't know what to do and I knew I
could do,
I knew I could help you financially.
Yeah,
I knew I could do that.
So I did that immediately,
but I didn't know what to do.
I don't,
I didn't,
didn't know what it feels like and I
didn't know what would it be the path to
take.
But when you offered that you were
having problems with your psychiatrist
and the medication and I said,
okay,
well let me,
let me get ahold of Matt,
who I know will know the right people.
I think I see people,
they don't tell me anything.
Yeah.
You were like,
oh,
it was like you were,
you're such a non complainer that I knew
when I always tell people this story,
we were playing pool and Ari's limping
around the table.
I'm like,
what the fuck happened to your leg man?
Fucking spider bite or something.
I go,
what?
Let me see your fucking leg.
And he pulls his pants up like a dude,
you got to go to the hospital right now.
You have a very bad staph infection and
this could fucking kill you.
Like,
come on,
you're joking.
I start unscrewing my cue and Mike,
we're going to the hospital now.
It was so bad.
But the fact that you're so stoic that
you will,
you never complained once while you have
this gigantic pus filled sack on your
knee killed.
It was horrible,
man.
One posted the juke lamb video and they
were,
he was like,
do you know that there?
And he's like,
ah,
it's bogging you,
not me.
So when you were,
when you were telling me that you were
doing bad and it wasn't,
you weren't feeling good and you were,
you were telling me you were suicidal.
I was like,
okay,
stop.
We got to now this is,
we're going to figure this out.
You know,
I don't know what to do.
We're going to figure this out.
Maybe nervous cause I was nervous that I
wasn't going to be there when you needed
me to be the hair and you know,
and you,
I would just,
I would just get the call just to get
the call.
Yeah.
I mean as a friend,
that's the last thing you want to do is
have some situation when you feel like
maybe you could have called them and you
could have made them feel better and
you,
they would've just gotten over that hump
and then they would have been okay.
Like you became okay man.
I mean you were my most depressed friend
and now you're probably one of my
happiest friends.
Even after I started seeing that guy,
it's still took months before finding
the right pill and then the right dosage
and then he would talk to me every like
30 days or whatever it was.
Yeah.
I remember you describing the process
and one of the things that was
disconcerting to me was how random it
seemed to be.
What do you mean?
Which pills they chose and then it's
like they're guessing.
That's what seemed insane to me.
I felt like if you like say,
you know,
then you got an infection.
They know which antibiotic works best on
that infection.
Boom,
they give it to you.
But this one wasn't that cut and dry.
It was,
they were just trying stuff out on you.
Yeah.
It's like,
oh,
you need Ibuprofen,
you have an inflamed thing.
It'll took it down.
But they know generally.
Yeah.
This is like there's,
from what I get gather,
there's two things could be wrong with
you.
You either have too much dopamine,
too little dopamine,
too much something else or too little
something else.
Huh.
And so each of these pills,
I think they're into two categories or
four categories.
And they either,
they either affect the dopamine or they
effect the other thing,
either limited or push more in and then
the other,
so they don't know which one's doing it
to first.
Uh,
and then once they narrow that down,
they've got to decide if it's like
getting too much of it or too little.
I don't know if you're bipolars are
separate thing,
they're just guessing.
And then while you take this shit,
you've added the horrible feelings and
then added some awful side effect and it
just like,
ah,
this is one of the things that I really
wanted to point out when when Bruce
Roseanne was going to come on,
I wanted to really talk about medication
and how we're,
we're asking this really,
you know,
she's an elderly woman who's taking an
incredible amount of medication.
She's taking a lot of shit.
She takes ambien every night.
She's drinking,
she's smoking pot and she's on a host
and meds and these things are all doing
battle in her head and she barely knows
what the fuck she's saying.
Some of the time she's saying it.
She's in an ambient Hayes's in and out
of it and she's open about it.
You know,
she's like,
I need to get them to adjust my meds.
But everybody's is attacking her.
Like she can never recover.
She's feel righteous.
But it's weird because I was such at the
forefront of putting on like homosexuals
into mainstream media.
You know,
she didn't give a shit and suddenly it's
like,
no,
it's all gone.
You from a joke and people like she
wasn't joking.
I'm like for sure she was joking whether
or not you think she should have used
those words.
And by the way that that lady does look
fucking Jewish.
His shit that she was talking about.
But like to say it's not a joke.
Let me just explain to everybody as a
professional comedian,
as an expert in this,
when someone says this person looks like
a mixture of this and this,
that his joke form,
that's not a,
that's a pure joke.
That's what that is.
You see that over and over again.
You see this person looks like this
mixed with this.
This guy has a work ethic of this works
with the,
it's like that's a joke for,
that's clearly a joke.
Yeah.
To say it's rice,
it's fine.
Whatever.
But the sign is not a joke.
You're being ridiculous.
Yeah.
It's obviously a joke.
It just,
you can't say that joke.
That's what we were saying.
Yeah.
I was like,
it's not a joke cause you can't say that
choke.
Yeah,
definitely joke.
But if she was black,
she'd be able to tell a joke easy.
Like if Miss Pat said that joke instead
of Roseanne and everybody be like,
ah,
she does look the water related in any
way from her fucking conservativeness.
Yes.
Well she's also Nadea Squirrel Shit.
She just is and she loves to go on
twitter and talk crazy stuff and she had
apologized leading 200 times a day.
George Soros for calling him a Nazi and
like it's so much instill continues to
tweet.
She's tweeting like crazy.
It's all insane,
man.
You gotta you gotta if you're doing
network thing and they got it,
they got your friends got to take away
or twitter and various all about shit.
Okay.
You just can't use,
those are going to get you on something.
You just can't.
We have an operator got a hundred people
working on that set.
They all,
all of them actually they're going to
switch over to,
they're going to call it some new show
now.
Right?
The con isn't,
but by the way,
I don't think.
Yeah,
I don't think they should have fired
her.
I really don't.
I don't think so.
You got to let her apologize.
And you know,
she explains herself and you realize who
she is and she's not terrible person.
She's not so easy to put somebody as one
action.
This is something I read a biography of
her conversations on songs to key,
uh,
me and mark leader.
It was like house arrest for 20 years.
She was a Nobel peace prize prize for
writing.
Um,
and she was talking about the Burmese
army who was torture her.
I had,
uh,
you know,
killed and arrested forever.
A lot of her colleagues and there was
like,
look,
they're not all bad.
You can't make someone into one of their
actions.
So just goes,
even if you've committed murder,
one of the worst things you can do that
is not who you are.
You're just someone who has committed
murder.
She goes,
now there's a certain point,
we've done so much murder that you now
are really wholly a murderer.
Right?
But that's very rare.
What's much more common if someone who
has killed somebody,
they're now no longer that person.
20 years later,
I have someone who kills,
you know,
and if to make somebody to one of their
actions is,
it's dehumanizing to all of us.
It is.
And it's also,
there's targets where people see someone
who leg is a Roseann who's like some
sort of cultural icon and they like to
shift it on them and attack them.
They like to go after them when some,
there's been some transgression,
they'd done something which she did do.
If you know,
it upsets people.
So they want to attack in.
Oh a go really unbalanced way.
They want to end it all for her.
There's no way you can ever,
uh,
bounce back from that.
Yeah.
They don't want,
they wanted pile on and want to kick
people whether down.
Cause now it's my chance to kick you.
It's a terrible lack of compassion.
That comes from two things.
I think one,
it comes from a jealousy.
There's a natural jealousy that we all
have four super successful people.
When they fail,
they go,
ha ha,
I knew it.
I knew it,
And now I have justification to attack
you.
I think there's a little bit of that.
And I think there's also,
when people feel like shit,
they want other people to feel like shit
too.
Yeah.
You know?
And I think this is what I think these
attacks on people,
these rabbit attacks,
it's not coming from you.
It's not coming from me.
We're not screaming for the death of
Roseanne.
And even the people that are really the,
most of the people just go,
that's fucking bullshit what you did.
And then the network,
here's all these people say,
that's bullshit.
Yes.
You know,
I think it's just,
it's symptom of where human beings are
today.
I think there's so many human beings
that are hurting,
and so when something comes up and gives
them a legitimate to be upset,
they just attack it full force.
But what disturbs me is the lack of an
overwhelming voice for compassion.
The lack of an overwhelming voice of
people saying,
Hey,
look,
real,
real racism is awful.
But this lady who probably did commit
real racism by calling the cops and that
eight year old girl,
she's just a fucked up person.
What does this all better?
To just forgive her.
What happened to like,
here's,
I think there's some mistakes that the
left and the right makes when trying to,
like when there's an e mob,
you know,
it's,
they seek to punish over,
educate.
They're not looking for,
to make the person changes their
opinion.
They go,
you're ignorant.
And then they leave it at that.
So probably the thing I got the most
flack for in my life was the amazing
racist videos.
Um,
Gee,
I wonder why.
Yeah,
I mean over and over,
getting new people find it and say,
fuck you,
you're racist.
I have maybe gotten three texts message.
I mean,
I've gotten hundreds and hundreds of
death threats.
I've gotten thousands and thousands of
angry fuck you's racist.
Racista I'm whatever,
but maybe only three total.
And I can really think of too of people
going,
hey,
just so you know,
this is why that hurts me because I was
an immigrant here.
And then when I see stuff like this,
it reinforces the feeling that I'm like,
maybe that's it.
Of the thousands and thousands of the
other way of fuck you.
So you're not really trying to educate
and you want to change their opinion.
You really just trying to like lash out.
Yeah,
so what is that?
Why are we all like that?
Because we're unhappy and you find a
target and you got a free shot.
You ever see a guy go down in the
ghetto?
You ever see a fight where a guy goes
down the ghetto and everybody runs in
and kicks him in the head?
You see any of those?
There's a gang of those on a street
fight videos.
There's a bunch of street five videos
and some of the craziest ones are in bad
neighborhoods where someone gets knocked
out and then where else?
Bunch of people take free shots on him
while he's down and out to get a free
shot.
There's a bunch of videos like that and
there as a person who understands brain
trauma,
it's severely disturbing.
When I've talked to so many of these
neuroscientists about the,
like all these blunt force impacts on
the brain,
you're seeing the guy was totally
unconscious and they want walk by and
soccer kick him in the head while he's
totally unconscious,
just take turns hitting him full blast
in the face.
And a bunch of people do it.
They stop him,
they kick him.
I mean he's out cold with his pants down
and they are kicking him in the head.
I don't think people [inaudible] the
effects that one of those he rages can
have on your psyche.
And I think when people,
they see something like the lion guy or
that dude who fucking caught a foul ball
and the cubs game or fuck head metzger
or anything like that.
Or they say this lady with the short
girl,
it comes at you from everything
everywhere.
And then pick the site like the,
the zeitgeists moves on,
you know,
people kind of move on and think
something else.
They're still getting hundreds of stuff
a day saying fuck you.
Fuck you.
Yeah,
it's still happening.
Right.
And so you all move on like nothing
happened,
but everyone who's shit on them a little
bit has added to their this,
this
overwhelming like this thing you can't
get out.
I still think Mexico's flailing off that
shit off.
He's still trying to defend himself.
All these fucking attackers from fucking
five years ago,
like three years ago,
but like you don't just come clean on
that.
So all the people adding like,
hey fuck you for killing that lion.
Like you've added to their fucking break
in psychology.
It's not an easy thing to get over and
you don't see it all,
but it's so much,
I mean,
Brendan's easy start.
I called him and his wife might get
offline right now Ralphie too and that
shit was happening to him.
He was like,
you need to give this to someone else
because it won't do you want to go?
Even if you know you're wrong.
Where does he see apologize to all of us
six years earlier and said,
hey fuck,
I'm sorry I lied and we all made fun of
him.
That was over.
He doesn't need other people going,
fuck you.
You live with.
You already know.
I already told everybody I know I was
wrong.
You don't need a 10,000
people telling you that it doesn't do
anything for you when you've already
said yes.
I agree.
Yeah.
You know,
they don't care though.
They just want to get the licks in.
Yeah.
And it's terrible.
They are the cultural equivalent to this
bar fight kicking somebody down.
It's a free shots.
And they also want you to know they're
disappointed in you and express their
rage at you.
I'm following you.
All right.
Just do it.
Don't fuck a tilt while you're telling
me.
But that's adorable.
When they let you know,
unfollow.
Ouch.
Jones was right.
MMM.
Yeah.
It's,
it's uh,
it's a nutty time we live in.
Yeah.
It is a nutty time and it's a time of
outrage.
If there's,
there's outrage sport out there to be
had and there's,
you know,
there's legitimate outreach.
Both,
both things are happening.
My friend told me about these people in
DC.
I'm pulled over on the side of the road,
decently busy highway,
uh,
maybe sunset boulevard type thing,
but not businesses like that.
But at busy,
like let's say three lines here,
three lines there,
that's all these two kids walking home
and 10 year old and eight year old
that's on their own,
just walking.
Um,
and this lady pulled over.
I was like,
what?
Who are you?
Where's your parents?
And they're like,
I dunno,
I think they're probably at home.
I'm not sure.
I'm just like,
well,
where are you going?
She said,
we're going home.
Like,
where are you coming from?
Like we're coming from the playground.
And she was like,
no,
you can't be on your own.
And she called the cops and that got
them,
you know,
pick them up and got them to where they
lived.
And the parents were there and like,
what's all this?
And they're like,
we saw your kids walking alone.
yeah,
well for the park,
right?
And they were like,
yeah,
the look.
Yeah,
we taught them how to do that.
And they're like,
what do you mean?
We taught them,
we've walked with them from the park
enough times and we taught our kids
enough to where we trust that they can
come home for the PUK alone.
We've taught them how to do that.
We trust them with it.
And then people are like,
oh,
I guess so.
And there was a split in the story.
Most people read it.
90% of the people who read it called
yes,
parents should be allowed to trust when
their kids are trained enough to do
things like driving at 16.
That's a parent's decision.
You know?
Um,
10% of the people were like,
no,
I wouldn't do that with my kids.
That's fuck them.
And those people reached out on twitter
on facebook and said,
fuck you.
Chevy kids taken away from you.
And that 10%,
even though 90% said,
yeah,
my parents should be able to teach their
kids whatever that 10% means.
Thousands of people coming at you saying
you're a horrible teacher.
You're a horrible father.
Imagine that.
If thousands of people say,
fuck you,
you're a bad father,
you're ruining your kids.
And it kept happening.
It affects you.
And they didn't do anything wrong.
They didn't tell you about 90% of people
think,
yeah,
you're in the right here and you're
still getting all this negativity.
Well,
nobody imaging is shit and nobody ever
is prepared for them.
No one's prepared for it.
No one agents,
agencies should have,
should be on the ready to help their
client fucking deal with this when it
happens,
because it will happen to almost
everybody.
You'll have something that will get
blown out of proportion.
You gotta be,
you got to get offline immediately.
The well,
do you think that some of it comes from
people have this feeling that anybody
who is in that sort of a situation with
a clearly wrong,
it was just an open target.
Oh,
target.
Fuck them.
I can go off on them.
Look how easy it is to a Christianity
joke.
Now look how hard it was back then and
for scientology,
same thing in south park.
Broker up and now you're like,
you're not brave from making front of
Scientology.
Now Christianity,
everybody's doing it.
Yeah,
that whole brave.
So make it easy.
Now do that.
the 60s you have a problem.
Did Not get exhausting.
Brave telling jokes,
how much just be funny.
Yeah,
but John,
Tom,
I,
I had a great joke.
It's already been covered.
He goes,
I've got a great story.
how much is a funny one you made up?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
True Story.
Like I don't need a true story.
How about a good one?
Yeah.
I guys,
I don't need a true story.
Yeah,
yeah.
Wait,
what?
We're just saying.
I forget.
What were we just saying?
Jamie,
you forget to,
God dammit fucking marijuana.
It's got it.
Side effects.
It does have its side effects.
Definitely.
There's no doubting that you were
talking about he rage.
Yeah.
Medsker z rage is pretty rough people.
He hasn't gotten out of that yet.
Oh yeah.
People to fucking man.
Fuck you.
I just feel like we're stalled out in
our cultural evolution in a way that I
feel like we're,
we're in these movements of change and I
think I see a lot of positive things,
but I don't see nearly enough like
friendliness and compassion.
I think we really need more of that as
human beings.
This is not lasting.
You're not going to last.
No one's lasting.
You know,
you're going to die.
We're all going to die.
We're here for a certain amount of time.
It's not permanent.
And while you're here,
we can make everything better for
everybody.
Just being nicer to each other.
It can be done.
I mean,
it's not going to be done.
So I think,
but he can be done a little drifty.
I think what you do has got affect your
own life.
Say I can't change it for everybody,
but what I can do is every time every
one of these blogs make them angry,
it just go.
I probably don't have the whole story on
this cause that's happened 20 times
already.
Oh,
for sure.
So then it's like,
I'm not gonna get mad.
You know what I am going to,
I'm sure people are taking care of this.
What I'm going to do is go outside and
enjoy some freedoms that I have like a
fucking park,
you know,
actually enjoy your life instead of
letting people fucking take you down
this horrible road to hurt them.
You're hurting
yourself and you're wrong or hurting
them.
Fucking get out there.
Just leave.
We call a friend.
Go talk about something.
Yeah.
It was just a strange time for,
you know,
just for expressing anger.
Fuck you.
You're wrong.
Fuck yeah.
Fuck you.
You're rolling.
We'd never had like more of an open
forum for debating ideas,
but people have never been more dogmatic
and aggressive about their opinions too
and the left gets violent.
Now this is a weird thing that didn't
use to happen before.
Like Shun Nick Depaulo get punched in
the face by some woman at a show self
righteous that you feel like he has had
a punch him in the face,
got a giant black eye and it's like you
can't be violent against someone.
And they use ago,
we'll look who you're,
let's say it was like a dice type act
and then some of those people were like
hardcore kkk pepper people like look who
your fan base is and you're like,
that's not my fault.
I'm not going to be there.
Well if you want that logic,
some of the people following you guys
are pretty fucking shitty.
Yeah.
I will call you on that logic cause I'm
not a hypocrite but like it ain't your
fault.
But like they are.
Some of them are getting fucking violent
now.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
So antifreeze page,
it's,
it's so much of information.
It becomes idea wars and when it becomes
idea wars they'd get this.
Anything necessary by any means
necessary mentality and they think that
sometimes justify the means.
It's fucking professors out there had
been quoted to saying that they believe
in violence when there is no other
solution supporting Antifa.
Antifa is disruptive violence and to
take away a pressers and that free,
this is a big one.
This is one that has been coming up
lately more,
more often.
Even the ACL,
you change his stance on free speech and
they,
they're deeming free speech is something
that's not hurtful to someone else.
Well,
that's not what free speech is.
Like what is the most recent,
most recent reading about free speech?
There's something about the Eclu stance
on free speech,
but you can't in French,
my belief is you can't fringe on their
such fine as long as you don't fringe on
the rights of someone else.
Right.
So like you can burn a flag if you want,
but you can't burn a flag in my
apartment.
I don't think.
I think they're shifting concern right
through to what harm is.
It's a gorgeous looking at physical harm
or monetary and physical or not.
We talk about like slight mental harm.
Well,
if it's racism,
it's clearly emotional harm,
mental harm.
You're,
you're damaging someone's psyche if
you're dismissing them in a racist way
or you're insulting them in a racist
way.
I think that's one of the things not
wanting to white people.
Here's the problem with sec.
Okay.
So I heard this theory that like making
fun of white people and dismissing Ypo.
Yeah.
Fuck you white guy.
You don't know anything.
All right,
well that's,
you've just put me into a category that
I'm in.
Just race,
human.
I mean,
I know you don't like when people do
that til he was.
So I don't know why you're using those
methods now.
Does it make sense to me?
Well,
it's the tide coming in and out right
there.
The whites owned slaves for so long and
it was so fucking oppressive that now as
it's shifted back,
there's still economic despair and all
black neighborhoods because of racist
laws and things have bounced out yet.
So you're allowed to go fuck white
people.
So you're allowed to fuck white people
until
it goes this way and this way.
And then he got to the point where you
shitting on Christians and I'm not a
Christian.
I don't care for them.
Uh,
especially Catholics,
but like we're shitting on them now.
It's like,
Hey,
can you come on and leave them alone?
They're honestly,
all they do is take abuse.
Now,
all they're doing is trying to worship
their God and you guys are shitting on
them and calling them yokels and leave
them alone for a minute.
They're,
they,
they're down.
They're down.
You've got them down.
You're not punching down if you want,
if you want to shit it on a Catholic.
Yeah.
Unless they're fucking kids.
Do whatever.
You will join it.
Wait,
wait.
Do Yo know,
right.
Well you said what you said that is,
I mean,
that is one of the darkest fucking
thinks that they're accused transfer and
people go rapes all over the place.
That was the pope.
Pope did that.
Yeah.
Here's an organized guy who talks to
God.
That's what,
that's what God told him to say.
And he moves somebody who went on to
rape a hundred deaf kids.
Yeah.
Hundred.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um,
what the fuck,
man.
You look into that guy's background,
ratzinger and look into it.
I mean,
there's several cases of that.
There's so many,
there's documentaries on it,
I think.
Speak no evil is one of the
documentaries of a different priests
that were just molesting just scores of
kids.
Damn.
Yeah.
And they interviewed the guys.
They're monsters.
It's so crazy,
man.
They were just,
that's what they did.
That's what everybody did to them.
That's what they did.
And they got away with it
forever.
If we once in a while someone will point
out some like Jewish rabbi that like has
raped a kid or something like that.
As I see it happens in Judaism to okay,
what does this acl use?
Longstanding commitment to defending
speech we hate is this recent good.
That's what they should be doing in
response to this.
Oh,
so somebody published a someone's
criticism published in the Wall Street
Journal,
uh,
is different from those challenges to
our work.
Her critique is pr is predicted.
Oh,
predicated on a fundamental
misrepresentation.
She falsely accused of the Acl,
you of having secretly changes policy
and regarding free speech and of
launching an investigation to determine
who leaked the secret.
Uh,
air quotes leaked and then quote,
secret document that she claims revealed
this asserted change in policy.
In fact,
the Aclu remains fully committed to
defending free speech as a document.
She cites expressly with firms
expressing reforms.
Um,
Hashtag fake news.
So somebody put out some fake news
according to the Aclu.
Good.
I heard somebody say,
it's hard to tell.
You should not be able to,
uh,
this was like on a fucking something and
say once there's violence committed
because of your,
um,
organization,
you can no longer say you're not a
terrorist organization where you can no
longer say you have the right to protest
when it causes violence.
And then this was on npr actually,
and then the coast was like,
okay,
so just so you know though,
under the,
and there are liberal group,
I'm not crazy,
but like liberal arts.
Okay.
Just so you know.
Then they'll apply that same thing to a
black lives matter.
And he's like,
what do you mean?
Like,
well,
that guy who killed two cops because of
the black lives matter.
If,
if you're going to say the followers
decide whether or not it's,
then we have to outlaw of black lives
matter.
And that guy was like,
oh,
no,
no.
Can't do that.
I was like,
all right,
well
then you can't say Charlottesville.
People don't have a right to say go
home.
Kikes you're taking our jobs.
They can say it.
It's fine.
It sucks.
They can say it.
Yeah.
All of it.
You've got to say all of it.
You can even roll your eyes and say,
that guy's an idiot.
That's your right.
You don't stop them from talking because
then it keeps going to the point where
rap is getting fucking boycotted in
America.
You can't put your shit out.
It goes.
It will always go to a point where it'd
be super,
super repressive.
Well,
if one person who is not doing anything
wrong can't speak,
you've done something wrong.
You could easily compromise a group two
and turn it into a terrorist
organization by infiltrating it,
having someone caused violence and it
did occupy Wall Street.
Exactly what?
Sending some undercover cops start fist
fights and then they get brought that I
could go home this fist fights now.
Yeah.
Kids that were hanging around in occupy,
we're saying that they would run into
undercover agents and undercover cops
all day,
but would,
the guys they knew were undercover and
they're like,
what the fuck?
So they're just like being overwhelmed
by people who are lying to them.
And for the government to keep the peace
like this,
they're like secret covert agents
hanging around with these occupied kids.
Yeah.
You know,
you ever see,
one of my favorites is when Peter
Schiff,
who the venture capitalists banker,
Genius Guy.
Have you ever seen Peter Schiff been on
my podcast a few times,
super wealthy,
successful business guy.
And uh,
he went down to occupy Wall Street and
he said,
uh,
I don't know how he sat up.
I'm a multimillionaire.
Come,
uh,
explained to me what I've done wrong or
something along those ways are I,
I forget what his actual,
that's fun.
That's a patrol.
What was a great troll?
Because he's a financial genius.
He understands the market inside and
out.
They don't know what the fuck they're
talking about.
And he's like,
look,
I,
I employ hundreds of people.
I have a,
an enormous business.
I make tremendous amount of capital.
Why should you make the same amount of
money as me?
And she's fucking tortures these people
because he speaks a fucking hundred and
50 miles an hour.
And they don't know what they're saying
and he's just,
he's,
it's,
it's very comical to watch and it just
shows you how people go into these
things with these idealistic ideas of
what they think they're standing for
when they don't even have like a
framework of what they're against.
The policies and the banking and the
corporations and capitalism in general.
They don't have a,
there's so many people that do,
but most people don't.
Most people that are there,
they're there for the ride.
It's like,
okay,
fuck the man man,
you're going to fix things.
So Peter Schiff is the man so he gets
out there amongst them with fucking
beautiful $5,000
suit on.
It probably costs more than Nice.
Probably angry.
And right now,
I mean you can watch these videos on
youtube.
They're hilarious.
That's great.
He,
I want to talk to him cause he set up
shop in Puerto Rico right before the
hurricanes came and shut all the power
off.
He was living in Puerto Rico.
Apparently a lot of people move to
Puerto Rico.
Not all rich people because fuck this.
Yeah.
Because the tax is there just like
stupid low.
My friend has lived there.
Yeah.
Susie,
um,
went to college together and she's like
the power like really in the last month
or two just came back on and it's being
held on by a bandaid and it,
hurricane season is starting soon.
Hurricane season.
Oh No.
It's like,
it's just going to happen again.
So how long has the power out for months
and months.
Oh my God.
And they got it back in few places and
then it kept going in other places
people died because of lack of power.
No,
we ain't doing shit,
but it's what is in the eyes of regular
people.
Like most Americans are busy with their
regular lives.
Puerto Rico's not a part of us,
even though it is.
Yeah.
I love it.
Everybody's like,
Oh,
you idiot trump.
Uh,
Puerto Rico is part of America is part
of America.
And I remember he like,
yeah,
you just found this out right now.
I knew it was because I used to have a
joke about Alaska being a frozen Puerto
Rico.
Oh,
let's not even attached.
Like,
how has that ours,
and that was Hawaii are so fucking place
way over there.
But yeah,
all the power goes out in Alaska.
We keep helping them.
Right.
What do we look at it if it's not a
state cause before he goes,
not a stage four because they're Puerto
Rican is part of it.
They always want to do this too in that
backlash on things.
They want to narrow it down to one
possible thing and it's like it ain't
one possible thing.
It's you have to give it up for all of
it.
Right.
You know?
Yes.
Perhaps it's because they're not white
because they're Latino ish.
Uh,
perhaps it's also mixed in with the ads
are not a full state wish.
I knew enough about finances to ask the
question,
is it possible that the reason why these
corporations and these rich dudes wants
a movie wants to move there and,
and get such a low tax rate that they
have to pay is also why they didn't have
the money to recover from this
infrastructure being down.
And so that these two might somehow or
another be correlated,
or is it just that,
that the hurricane was so fucking
overwhelmingly devastating that it just
took forever to fix?
Which one is it?
Because anybody who thinks you don't
need government,
we have to sit down and talk about how
we're going to fix things.
We're going to have to sit down and talk
about infrastructure.
We have some local government,
but you would,
what does that mean?
Like there's no government.
People are crazy.
Today in Puerto Rico,
nine months after Hurricane Maria,
2,609
six 2,669
customers still do not have power.
In many cases,
these homes were more than one or where
more than one person lives.
It may be another months before they get
it.
We're going to tweet about this until
the last customer has power.
And this is,
uh,
David,
Ben,
God,
b.
N.
B.
E.
G and big nod e.
G correspondent.
David just read his name.
David.
How big is that?
A French real big hell from Louisiana.
They've been y'all.
That's fucking crazy.
Nine months after the hurricane,
the hurricanes are coming again.
That comment there.
Fuck didn't,
I'm sorry Susan.
Which dude?
Branson.
Didn't he buy an island that goes got
completely decimated?
I think so.
I think the whole island got wiped off
the face of the map.
I think there's for the first time and
like 300 years.
No human beings live on an island too,
dude.
What the fuck you imagine living in a
place where the sky becomes an angry
monster and just rips houses apart.
You should have seen some of these
fucking torrential rains and like his
team orange it like that where it's like
it's going in like oh drop job,
get to cover now.
And if you don't get to cover in a
minute,
your underwear soaked.
I mean is through you.
All your stuff is ruined too.
And then it passes in like 30 minutes.
Do you remember when we were in Miami?
Will you with me when we,
when Eddie Bravo was doing a seminar and
we drove down from West Palm Beach to
Miami and we had a stop on the highway
too much.
There was so much rain.
All car stopped on the highway,
this ranch,
it was fucking crazy and all I could
think of is I hope no asshole tries to
drive through this 60th.
That's pretty limited.
I can just fucking fucking calm.
I'm coke.
It was insane.
We had to stay put and it was a wall of
water around us everywhere we looked.
Fuck man.
That was insane.
Yeah.
Damn.
That's a crazy thing about this world is
that you go to different places and just
by the universe pot,
you're at earthquakes and south places,
hurricanes and others.
I can pay attention to why.
No,
they're losing hundreds and hundreds of
houses to the volcano.
The volcano.
Really?
That's how the piano,
dude,
it's fucking up like a one time thing.
You,
it's fucking up everything and they say
it could go on for months.
It,
they have projectiles flying through the
air that are like s like fucking several
hundred pound rock Laogai hurling
through the air and landing on shit and
lighting things on fire.
Yeah,
dude,
they're losing houses left and right.
They can't stop it.
They came and slow it down.
You just have to get out of there so
they just have to evacuate.
This toxic fumes in the air is all all
around where the volcanoes are.
Look at it,
which,
which island or could see it from space.
Oh my God.
That's fucking space,
bitch.
Look at it.
What is it?
The main island.
The big one.
Wow.
Yeah,
the big island dude.
It's huge.
It's a fucking real problem.
Wow.
Yeah.
Look at that.
We'll go to scroll back up to the last
one.
That one right?
They look at that shit.
We're looking at this insane ocean.
Beautiful image.
It's on Forbes.
It's a beautiful image of how green and
lush,
the Big Island looks beautiful for 90%
of the patients and amazing.
But this lava is shooting out of it and
it's quit a people live.
Well,
this house has warehouses down there,
so,
so one thing that all that stuff to the
left,
that little brown shit,
that's like a little village.
A lot of those houses.
Yeah,
I saw it eat that Mustang.
That must've,
yeah,
that was cool.
Yeah.
The Mustang got cooked.
It was weird.
Just watching it consume it.
Like that's it.
You're so much,
that kind of nature is so amazing that
people
with,
that's how
you get an island.
So yeah,
exactly.
That's Iceland is all volcanic rock.
And then just sort of going over the top
of it and just stuff grew out of it.
Yeah.
I mean that is literally how the Big
island was formed.
It's being formed right now and you
freaking out,
you're going to have extension.
If I can calm down,
it's gotta be bigger.
Yeah.
Hawaii is going to be bigger and you've
got to put some tarp while you're
fucking building shit.
They have this shit there.
They call vog.
It's like volcanic smog.
Yeah,
man.
Uh,
it really fucked with my daughter's
head.
Um,
she gets a,
she was sneezing and coughing and I was
like,
what's the matter?
And they said for some people,
if they have allergies to certain
allergies,
um,
you can get this dog,
this weird fucking fog that comes in
that's mixed with volcanic,
volcanic,
uh,
either admissions or,
you know,
there's a lot of,
a lot of stuff that these people were in
danger of is not just the volcano
itself,
but the toxic gas.
Yeah.
And so some of those gases that leak
from the volcano get in the fog and some
people are particularly susceptible to
it.
Yeah,
I remember that European one where
everybody was like,
all the crops are ruined.
Oh yeah.
Was that the Iceland one where they,
do you know,
that's the one that was,
that was the one that was responsible
for that Michael Hastings guy.
Do you know Michael Hastings?
He's that journalist that they,
his career?
No,
no,
no.
He was over there doing a story on a
general for rolling stone and they had
the volcano happen and he couldn't fly
home for a long time.
So he's over there embedded with the
soldiers for a long period of time.
And during that time they got a little
loose with them.
And started being themselves and you
know,
some general said some stupid shit about
Obama,
you know,
insulted them in some way and they got
this and I still write general,
no,
no US general because this guy was doing
a story overseas and as he was doing the
story overseas,
he got stranded there because of the
volcano.
So Michael Hastings,
right,
this very bad story about this general
and then comes back and you know,
the general gets fired.
Uh,
he,
he loses his job and he's like a beloved
general.
And so Michael Hastings then winds up
driving his fucking car into a tree,
going 120 miles an hour on sunset.
And the,
the fear was that someone had murked
him.
What they had done is they had hired
someone to take over his car because
he's got one of them modern Mercedes
where it just hack into an hack into it.
You could force those things to drive
themselves.
You could do,
you could literally get into the
computer and turn,
shift the wheel.
A hastings found himself on a bus from
parents to Berlin with mcchrystal and
his entourage.
The visit,
which was supposed to take place in two
days,
turned into a month during which time
hastings had considerable access to the
general.
So the,
the big conspiracy theory was that he
was murdered.
That was the big conspiracy because his
car,
the engine flew from the car.
I mean it was like,
it exploded,
like to do some sort of explosion in
there.
And then there was also the toxicology
examine toxicology examination,
I'm pretty sure revealed we looking for
the,
revealed that he was a on some sort of
amphetamine,
but all writers are on adderall.
Not all of them,
but a shit load of them.
Right.
Mike Lawrence that were in the Cabo
Festival.
And um,
and uh,
we're smoking pot,
shitty pot,
Mexican pot.
And I was like,
[inaudible] no,
I don't smoke pot.
It was like,
why don't you Mike?
And he goes,
I'm trying to get writing jobs.
I don't want to get tested.
I'm like,
oh dude,
Hollywood doesn't test for drugs.
Are you kidding me?
I'm trying to get started.
Right.
It was just starting.
I was like,
they're all long coke weed.
They don't test for that Bro.
That's hilarious.
Testing writing chops.
He imagined how shitty the movies you'd
become called.
So horrible.
You're testing somebody for a weed.
It,
it'll be awful.
It's three 30 ladies and gentlemen,
we've got to bring this bad boy to a
close.
We want to thank you all for tuning in.
Well let me say this already,
the great.com
go to [inaudible] dot com but I'm doing
this hour,
uh,
it Edinburgh.
That's Kinda what I geared at for,
for last year and a half to fucking
unveiling and Edinburgh.
So I've watched them for two times now.
I was out there and it's kind of got
influenced by someone that,
her style of comedy,
I think the only problem with this style
comedies,
they give up and we've talked about
this.
They give up the jokes for the sake of a
point or theme.
So I'm very careful not to do that,
to make all this,
it work on its own and clubs in America.
I like how you confidently pronounced
the name and Brah Brah Edinburgh is what
a lot of Americans go borrow Gogol and
run broke.
So I'll be there August 2nd through the
26th at [inaudible].
Tell all your friends from the UK that
are going to show to check out Ari
Shaffir Ju 6:00
PM everyday at the hive.
One more time with the dates.
August 2nd to go second through the 26th
that's the same son.
That's 24 days.
Ours should fear.
That's like Christmas bitch.
Come out.
Enjoy it.
Asleep asleep are the great dot.
But I would like to point out that I
offered Ari a free fanny pack.
He would not take it.
I said,
he will not tell you.
I said absolutely not actually.
Really like so proud.
You're like,
eh.
It's,
it helps when you're traveling.
You put your keys and your wallet in
there and you don't have to hold him.
He's like,
fuck you.
I have a reputation to maintain.
I'm free on a lot of stuff,
right.
Fanny pack free.
I'm fanny pack free son.
That's how I'm rolling.
Uh Okay.
We'll be back tomorrow.
Who's on tomorrow?
Joe Rogan,
Hamilton Morris from vice.
Would you want to Redo?
We did one many,
many,
many years ago and we got so high we
couldn't talk.
I'm like,
I'm here with the drug guy from vice.
We're going deep.
We went so deep.
I didn't even know if I was there or
not.
I wasn't even sure what I was hearing my
voice,
if it was mine,
we barely talked.
It was,
I was close to death,
but he's coming back.
He's going to be here tomorrow.
Hamilton Morris.
Um,
Duncan trussell is going to be here.
We've got a lot of people come and see
you soon.
Bye.
Hm.